And there's a there's a a hundred different points like that
where where this is like exactly is just Nick basically playing
soft defense but refusing to take any actual position or explain
anything. It's just like he's just he's just spoilering. He's
just like um trying to put a drag on potential criticism because
he's riding it. He's riding the wave. Well, the criticism is
that he's not spending enough time like providing like necessary
No, it's not even No, it's not spending enough time. is that
when points of criticism come up, he refuses to engage. It's
not you're not spending enough time. It's a deliberate effort
to not present any argument. So you cannot be criticized firmly.
You can't no one can say totally wrong. You fully believe like
Dioro is like a de dishonest actor at the moment. Yeah. On this
drama 100%
Hassan. He seems to be very caught up about someone calling him
a cryptofascist. And he's very car about the way these lefty
communities have treated him over the years. And he is willing
to use Ethan who is lashing out and doing world stuff and trying
to keep him at arms length so that he doesn't incur too much
damage.
Like the naked ape video makes Destiny seem like like a little
bit like Yeah. If you don't go and like watch the material behind
it, like a lot of it is bad for him regardless, but if you don't
go watch material behind it, then it's the guy. He looks absolutely
this guy text her. Let me go watch him. Let me go watch him.
Yo, this guy ignored my DM and and did not even did not even
go live. It's crazy. I'm going live next week.
Yeah, you've been saying that for three weeks, bro. Believe it.
Listen, I'm I've been busy, man. I've been busy. But no, this
uh here's the thing. I get too bored of commentary too easily.
You know what I mean?
Yeah. It's like it's it's uh I think you need to kill Nicholas
Dioro and then maybe he'll be No, he's based now. He's based
now. Did you see what Did you see his new stream tonight?
He like posted in his Discord. He's like insecure. He's like,
"Oh, Dan Dan redacted my DMs." He's like crying and himself,
dude. You read that as insecure. I He's exposing. He's like freaking
out. He's like freaking out and crying. Like going into his little
Discord hug box and like freaking out right now. R's just trolling.
See, I see that it's just he's exposing Dan. Dan's like freaking
out. Dan's mad at how that debate went. Dan's mad. This is my
cabal sweep. Dan's mad.
Dioro's exposing him. Dioro is uh Wait, but there is no exposing
Dan. You realize that, right? Dan will always say I'm
win, bro. I I don't know. Dan literally said this is how you
lie about people and I'll
Does he really say that? I know nothing about Dan. Yeah, Dan
is an open outright
liar. He is just like said he will say what he has to say to
win. And so an open liar that implies that he goes on stream
and he's like, "I'm lying. I know that I am, but I don't care."
I've had conversation with him on Jason's stream where he literally
says that he doesn't really care about truth. He cares about
winning.
Winning?
Yeah. He he literally said, "I'll say whatever I have to." What
is he What is he fighting for?
For the in Israel and against his unironically for the for his
Personal Yeah, it's personal vendetta against Hassan and the
Okay. What is his personal vet? Okay. Is Is it really like about
fighting Destiny lighting their group. Whatever. This feels like
I'm walking into like some like anti-semitic trap. I don't know.
No, you're not legit. Dan's nose in the picture. Yeah. Yeah,
for real. Antiic tropes. Well, he's can get away with it. I'm
not. I know. I know. I play this game, too. I know
that that will say like that. They're saying crazy about my people.
They're saying crazy about my people. Pay against my people is
allowed on this platform. We should have stopped it. He'll say
this. I did see this screenshot. I'll send it to Jtock. This
is like Dan from Dioro's chat tonight. And I just take this stuff
as like jokes, but like you guys are telling me this is like
legit. This is so funny to me. This is when Dioro was watching
I think uh uh legal mindset. Oh my god. You want to watch some
awesome legal mindset stuff? No. No. Wait, hold on. Do you know
which video Dario watched? Did he watch the defamation video?
It was the doxing one. And there was a doxy one. Oh, unlucky.
You know who was telling me a lot about legal mindset last night?
Who? Who? My boy Ethan Ralph. Me and Ethan Ralph were DMing a
lot last night. Yeah. And he he told me some people got drunk
on Twitter on 4th of July. Yeah. He told me some crazy stuff
about legal mindset. It's crazy. Did he tell you that he's like
runs a website that sells uh consultations to move people to
Thailand and explicitly like says you need to flee the west cuz
white women are all who go on sugar daddy websites. He did he
did point me in that direction. He didn't go into that much detail
though. That's crazy. He told me he says he helps other expats
in the area with their immigration. No other reason to go to
Asia permanently, let's be honest. And then Ethan Ralph talk
about some other stuff like pandering and reco drama and stuff
like that. I don't really know that stuff. But yeah, he told
me uh he's not a big fan. Legal sucker is what he calls him.
We got a lady boy mindset. Thailand only. Yeah. Relocation consultation.
This is one of the services he offers. Tells you how to like
set up your apartment, bank account,
uh internet, phone, medical care, aesthetic services like haircut
or any other accommodation needed upon moving to Thailand.
I feel like this guy definitely hooks people up with like with
like uh massage hookers and
I'm almost like low key when Ralph sent me that DM I thought
there was like some hyperbole going on there or some trolling
I don't know but I didn't know that this is literally on his
website accusing Hassan of defamation for saying that he's a
passport bro okay I don't know I don't know if this clip is cut
together exact but here I'll throw this clip up and see if okay
well Hassan had to have gone harder than that right didn't Hassan
say that he he said he's a fake lawyer was probably the hardest
he went Okay. Probably the worst thing he said was fake lawyer.
Not that he's some like
held back from the Elon Musk criticism. He didn't go that far.
Yeah. He said he's a passport bro. He said uh he does like right-wing
like rumble lawyer streams or whatever the He's a fake lawyer.
That's basically it. Wow. Trying to get this clip cut together
right now. Let's see if this uh let's see if this delivers it
correctly. Hassan has slandered me. committed some defamation
in response to my reaction to what was going on with Twitch and
the situation with Twitch. So, today I'm going to respond to
that publicly, clear up some of that uh misinformation, and also
talk about some hot water that Hassan may be in legally in the
state of California. Of course, I'm Andrew Esquire, American
attorney, and this is the legal mindset. teach you to be your
own judge who offers courses on becoming a passport bro who primarily
streams on rumble. Neither one of those things are true. I do
not have a single course on becoming a passport bro and I do
not primarily stream on rumble. I only stream on YouTube. So
yeah, there we go. Um Passport bro is interesting uh because
the definition of a passport bro is sent is
to me. So this is another video. I think you need to get let
him do his whole definition there.
You need to let him do his whole definition for the I realize
this is a nice smash cut, but trust me. Anyway, this is another
video he did. So, basically he says definition of a passport
bro is somebody who's like going here to like get only or something
and temporarily and like I'm a permanent I can actually probably
pull it up, but do I have it here? I do have it here. And I do
not primarily stream on Rumble. I only stream on YouTube. So,
yeah. There we go. Why do you guys come in here and ask for this
stuff? It's interesting. Uh because the definition of a passport
bro is sent is typically someone that would visit a location
for a short period purely for purposes. And uh for anybody who
knows anything about me, I'm a long-term resident of uh several
countries in Asia. I've been a resident of the Republic of South
Korea, the Kingdom of Thailand, the Philippines, and Japan. Uh
these are all wonderful, amazing countries. And I do help doing
what is bro
like why
all those countries? That's why. So that's that's what he does.
And then he's like, "But I'm not a passport bro cuz I'm a permanent
resident." And then we go over to his uh go back to this clip
here where I threw the clip up right here. This anybody could
be a passport bro. As long as you're leaving the West for the
East, I mean, you could be a passport bro. So if you're a guy
listening to this channel and you leave the US, you could qualify
into the definition. Amazing. He literally says the the phrase
like right there. Yeah. Yeah. And he's like, "Anybody who leaves
the West for the East could be a passport, bro." Any guy watching
that channel who leaves the West for the East could be a passport,
bro. The entire tagline for the channel is helping the everyday
person escape the collapsing West for the East. We will have
information on visas, relocation, housing, businesses, and more
with unfiltered, no BS explanations, offering practical advice
for those looking to make a permanent
So, his uh did he deny being like right-wing in his video? Yes.
So he doesn't play any politics in his videos. Yeah. It's so
but then his language like escaping the collapsing west. I mean
that's obviously like rightwing. Yeah. Yeah. And there's there's
like a bunch of videos he got about like um who's ruining anime
with wokeness and like that. It's all just like the most like
uh he does like right-wing law slop content. And he says he doesn't
do as well.
Right. He claims he doesn't cover drama as well, but he literally
covers dramas that don't even have a lawsuit involved. He would
just like try and put a legal analysis on it. Yeah. Speaking
of another guy that doesn't cover drama anymore. Uh I saw Destiny's
video on you. Uh he put out yesterday. Oh yeah. Yeah. He uh he
said that you said that mentally ill girls when they get they're
getting raped or something like that. Yeah. Which is an obviously
position that he's just maliciously lying to try to put on me.
And uh you've got like only only the lowest IQ individuals on
the planet could possibly believe that, right?
Look, if somebody has a clip of you making that claim, you're
cooked. But I mean, I haven't seen that yet. So, I know somebody
who believes it.
What is this here? William, I know somebody who loves throating
Destiny's. Oh my god. It's nobody in any leaks.
Everything Destiny is saying is true. And this is the same guy
Drew Stagger spent the last year saying having to mentally ill
people equals Yeah. See, I'm waiting for that clip to be produced
cuz I I've never heard you say that claim. I thought like calling
Destiny is because and again calling him a is hyperbole I assume
at least from you guys, right? Like it's not he's not literally
I don't think we literally accused him of we would say the term
and then we'd say like explicitly it means violent through electronic.
Yeah. Yeah. He doesn't care about girls consent. He'll share
their nude imagery with any random person on Discord. That's
I thought that's where the thing came from. Not like the uh he
goes after BPD girls. What was that? It was specifically about
the audio recording thing. It was like you're using an electronic
device to violate someone's consent in a way that they would
completely reject the interaction if they knew you were doing.
Right. So like it's sort of like we think of like I think most
people think of like any kind of deception as like it only rises
quite to that level if they would like completely reject um the
situation and have like some kind of trauma or something because
of it if they found out the truth and that absolutely applies
to situation and electronic means was used. So you could you
can easily make an argument e
applies obviously it's a tongue and cheek hyperbole
but it's like a very specific argument that isn't just well you
you mentally ill women so you're actually like that's not what
anyone was saying right well the criticism about him mentally
ill women I thought was just more so like you can't really feel
sorry for him when they explode on him because he knows what
he's getting into by engaging with people that are you know like
that, right? It's like you can't feel bad. It's like, oh, this
woman's like exploding on him and exposing all of his stuff and
going crazy and nuts or whatever, right? But it's like he knew
what he was getting into, so who who cares? I thought that's
kind of She like maliciously uses that mental illness against
them as well, right? Yeah.
Maliciously. Yeah, I I guess so. Yeah. I don't know. Yeah, I
saw that. I was just like I I mean if somebody has a clip of
you making that argument obviously again they've got you dead
to rights you know but what I just haven't I feel like if somebody
had a clip of me making that argument wouldn't that just be a
clip that constantly get thrown in my face is me saying something
totally and prevents me from actually correcting on the issue.
Doesn't this testing guy always say or if someone says something
about me just ask for a clip or just ask you know show me that
actually happened. Doesn't he always say like that? Yeah he doesn't
do it for anyone else. Very curious. Interesting.
I'm waiting for it, but we'll see. He uh he like actually like
unironically I realize you had to take my word on this. He actually
just maliciously lies about like everybody who walked away from
him who like was around like Yeah. Like everybody he just maliciously
lies constantly
like like knowingly like he will you could have had a conversation
with him about a topic. He will know your feelings, know that
like something annoys you, know that it's not the truth and he
will use that against you intentionally just consistently. I
know for a fact he maliciously Destiny is a guy who's very comfortable
lying about anything if he knows he can get away with it. Like
I've heard him like debate with uh Nick Fuentes before and Fuentes
will bring up how like Destiny tried to get his Twitch account
flagged and I've heard like three different Destiny Nick Fuentes
debates where that situation is brought up and Destiny literally
has a different story every single time and all of them are incorrect
where he's talking about like cuz I was there I I was a Destiny
watcher around 2019 around that time that this whole situation
happened. I remember what happened. You know, uh they did that
whole debate with uh Trainrex TV moderated by Asmin Gold and
after that debate uh Destiny was like, "Hey, like Nick says some
stuff like here's here's the way to flag his Twitch channel and
stuff like that." And then a day after that it was banned. And
anytime Nick presses him on that, you know, Destiny will give
like a different story of like either that never happened or
he did it first context is totally different or Yeah, exactly
like that. So, it's like I know for a fact just watching Destiny
myself that he does feel comfortable, very comfortable lying
uh when I know what he's saying is just completely wrong. So,
yeah. Yeah,
he uh he does this quite a bit, which like is weird. Like honestly,
there's like a lot of probably reasonable criticisms you could
have of me,
but I I don't know why he would just like make things up kind
of goofy. I mean to me like the biggest thing that you got owned
on I mean are we allowed to talk about the recent drama and stuff?
I don't know if you've covered that. I'll let you talk about
it right now for sure. Yeah. I I I think like the biggest thing
that like looked bad I think was the screenshot where you're
like oh I'd never somebody from the internet or somebody from
this community blah blah blah like
from January or whatever
and cancel me if I ever do is what you Yeah. Yeah. To me, that
that's that's the that's the part that I saw where I was like,
"Okay, you kind of got owned there or whatever." Okay,
realistic. I realized it looks like I'm virtue signaling on Destiny
there. I'm needling somebody who has multiple E relationships
who's in my Discord, unfortunately.
I'm like needling them and I'm like, "This is so cringe. Like,
check this out. Cancel me." Um,
there's there's like some nuance there, but realistically it's
like hypocrisy on e- dating and how cringe it is, which I realize
I'm I look super cringe now. It's not like a moral statement
like it's totally wrong to do this. Wasn't meant to be, right?
Well, it just is like one of those situations where it just looks
like it makes me think like whenever people say they'll never
do something. It's kind of like when people say like, "Oh, I'm
done covering this guy." Which is something I'm guilty of all
the time where I'm like, "All right, I'm done covering Boax.
I'll never cover again. And then it's like next week, you know,
you you end up covering jokes on the internet and you have to
whenever a content creator says never, it's just it's always
just like the biggest mistake they ever make because Oh, really?
you. So, would you ever child Oh, never.
Okay. I was just just confirming just to be clear. Good. We got
that on screen. This guy, that's a guy look awesome at
These are these debate tactics I've heard about, you know, apparently.
Yeah.
Um, but not not jokingly. If um if you look at that as like a
moral statement and you don't trust me when I say it's not and
you like actually are cons, I'm totally fine with somebody saying,
"Yeah, I don't want to watch you anymore." If that's I like I
don't
think look like great in that situation. All I see that is like
a situation where it's like if I ever see you make like a declarative
statement about yourself where it's like oh I'll never do X Y
or Z. I'm just going to take that like infinitely less seriously
because it's like okay are are you are you really are you are
you sure? Like you know that's kind of like the only situation
I saw from the recent drama where I thought you looked like bad
per se but you know I didn't think it was like that big of a
deal in the grand scheme of things cuz I mean I don't know. I
certainly wouldn't go and say that it makes Destiny look good
or it somehow like makes Destiny I don't know. Oh no. Well, I
think a lot of people were quick to like be like, "Oh, Destiny
vindicated Destiny 1." And I'm like, "No, no, no, no, no, hold
on." Like, brother, like this all there's evidence for that.
Uh, real quick before Aiden says anything, I needed to let you
know, Auggie. He said it in chat and then he mentioned me on
Twitter as well to let you know that you're gay. Tipster says
you are gay.
Yeah, I see him tweeting at me. He says, "Tell Augarc." I said
he's gay. That's rude. So, we are getting the Willie Mac debate.
What's happening? Oh, he reached out. I see I assume he's messaged
you and said he's accepted. Yeah. I don't know. I I talked to
Willie or whatever. I don't know if he's down for that, but um
you know, Willy's a good guy. He's a good guy. [__]
Of course you wouldn't, dude.
He's a good guy. Sweeping right now. You're sweeping so hard.
I do sweep. I sweep. We love Willie. We love Willie. We love
Willie. Yeah. You guys don't. I do. Sweep for your friends. Yeah,
I do. the same problem this community's had year after year.
Cry about Look, I reached out I I put it I put it out there on
public bounty. Okay, I risked my uh standing in the cabal by
throwing that invitation out there. Will you denounce Tommy C
live on the air?
Tommy C. Tommy C is a great old man.
You can't can engage with the question and ask about his age.
Ask will you denounce Now that you ask me about something Thomas
C said specifically instead of just will you denounce this person
as a whole? Yes. Will you will you denounce his existence on
the platform? Okay, that no. Ask me something that he said about
like Chud Logic or something like that
Let me say mooching off his wife.
He doesn't mooch off his wife. How does he make money then on
SFTP? He's been making money for like a decade now. He's an internet
He's an internet OG. You know, Tommy Cal
like how it's done. Tommy C invented YouTube streaming. I don't
know if you guys knew that. And uh I appreciate
I thought you were going to be based. Still what are you talking
about? What are you talking about? Aiden, you put out this cringe.
Can we talk about this cringe tweet? I might be in the minority
here in this call, but Aiden put out this tweet today. Yeah,
you Aiden tweets a lot of cringe. You're probably not going to
be in the minority. Aiden, you have that awesome tweet about
the IDF got taken down.
That is pathetic. Jto signing a popular opinion as always.
I I'm saying you really I've been in Discord calls where you're
like figuring out ways to rage bait most effectively.
Yeah. Which tweet is this? This one here. I assume this one.
Why is it Why is it that despite being proven to be a verifiable
liar who is completely who has completely exposed himself as
a snake and someone unwilling to handle criticism or confrontation,
large members of the commentary community to stand by Tommy C.
Very disheartening stuff. Okay, here's the problem I have with
this tweet is you're demanding of other people to not talk to
somebody you don't like. Okay. Yes. Yeah, I am. I feel like are
you Wait, what? Why did you say yes? Oh, go ahead. I don't know
why you just said yes. Classic. Well, because because Well, because
this guy's only friends are online cuz he moved to a country
where he hasn't learned the language despite living there for
like a
talking. I know. So, I know that if I can get his online friends
to stop talking to him, I know his wife already
ruin his life. What the Cuz his wife is out working. So, if I
get the people online to stop talking to him, it will be like
solitary confinement. It's going to be so funny. Oh my god. You
actually want this guy to starve? That's evil problem.
Does he destroy you in a debate? Aiden, I think I'll be fine.
What' you say? You want this guy dead? I I won't confirm or deny.
Wow. So, it's gotten that serious. I haven't followed any of
this stuff. I actually, unlike you, I actually have a life. No,
I'm just kidding. Oh, really? Yeah. Like Willie Mac. You're just
like a real life guy. Real life stuff. No, no, no, no, no, no.
Hey, I thought you like Willy. Why would you say like Willy?
No. You want to be like Willy, right? You want to be like Willy,
right? Listen, I'm not I'm not going to tell No, no, no, no.
I was joking there. I was joking there. Hey, listen. I I I just
don't like the call to arms of like, oh, you have to not talk
to Tommy C anymore. Listen, I Yeah, I'm telling you, you have
to not talk to Tommy C anymore. Okay, we're placing sanctions
on Tommy C. Yes, I have to pick uh Aiden or Tommy C. It's an
easy choice. What if we bring Tommy Stan hooked to confront him?
He's not going to show up because he can't handle any like
He can't handle any. He can't handle any this this fat this fat
wife mooching piece of smoking inside giving his entire family
secondand cancer. Okay, this guy
is cool. Will never ever ever
go in any a hostile environment where he does not have complete
control because he's a he needs to know that he can kick you
at any time and like play his little nuke effect so he could
like think he looks cool to like the the two like autist chat
and actually so cool. He did the nuke on Aiden. He did the Did
he I thought he hasn't done that bit in years. No, he did it.
He was like he goes get the out of my life and then does the
nuke. saying
on his head. Do you know how many times I've wanted to tell Aiden,
"Get the [__] out of my life." and then nuke him.
That's just based. Hello, Jy. I hope your Are you good? What
the hell are you doing? What the is that JT stock files? You
did. That's great. Huge things happening here. Clearly, Queen,
you know this JK guy is in love with you, right? Why does he
have a gift of you doing that?
This guy's free as hell, by the way. I like how I have art on
the stream, but Aiden doesn't. He's such an irrelevant caller
that nobody even bothered to draw him art on the stream. Who
are you? Oh, my mic was muted for all of that. That seems way
weirder now that you didn't have any of my I thought you were
just going insane. No, now that seems way weirder. I was like,
"Oh, I don't know why the audio is on." I was just showing off
like new tech. Big big new tech coming out. Okay, we got new
tech animations. Custom animations for people. I was like talking
through the whole thing and you guys were just letting it play.
What the I thought you were just like zanned the out. I actually
knew it was me. I just didn't say anything for too long. That's
where we did like the Kelly one as well. What else we got here?
Ugly.
Kelly owns you, Aiden. Kelly completely owns you. Kelly totally
mocked you that one time. I I will have my day of reckoning.
I actually never recovered from that. That was crazy. You guys
You guys mentioned Tipster. He like maybe two months ago he added
me on Discord. I accepted. I said, "Hi, Tipster." said, "You're
no nothing about a Minecraft story." He added me as a friend.
I said, "Hi, tipster." And he said, "You're an Fsler." He just
typed out the I don't want to say it. And then he unfriended
me after. And I was like, "What the fuck?"
I don't tippy.
I I Well, he says slurs. I I tried to get him to to play Pokemon
with me on stream. I thought it'd be good. I don't think he liked
that. I think that made him mad. Are you bad at Pokemon? Uh,
I don't know. Probably. Yeah.
Which Pokemon?
I was going to get him to play um Poke MMO, which you can just
play like Gen 1 through five, but like with your like online
with other people. Damn. It pissed him off though. Made him real
mad. I think a tipster can say that word because he's,
you know, he's got the power. That is true. That is true. It's
not evil for him to say that, right? Jesus. Sorry. Okay. You're
on the attack on hate train. I'm saying you're on the tech on
hat train. Yeah. I um So I don't really know who he was. I had
a bad take on him originally. Yeah. Yep. And I schooled you on
it. You conceded to me in private. So we by the time I talked
to you about Tekken, I had already changed my mind. No, you didn't.
This is total. You just can't give me a double to save your life.
I own it.
No, I I remember like originally like it was like a couple months
ago. I saw Hassan was uh just like ripping into him and I hadn't
even seen any of the context why and I just assumed like Hassan's
just like going into like his family or something for no reason,
but I didn't realize he put out this tweet or something where
he was talking about like my military dad. My father didn't didn't
fight. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. These guys push terrorist propaganda
on Twitch. Yeah. Well, because I put up my tweet, everyone was
like, "Uh, what the" And so I was I was like, "Wait, what's going
on here?" But yeah, no, I I think he's pretty fake. I also never
watch his content to be honest. I don't even care about like
the stuff. I just watch his content. He comes across very fake
and uh disgusting to me. Wait, you didn't hear what a Cheetos
said? What did Cheetos say? He said like when Techon talks it
like
Yeah. Jar, can you pull up this? I will pull this up right now.
Wait, wait, wait. I need to listen to this.
Let's get this up on the screen immediately. Are you putting
in chat?
I'm sending it in your DMs. Tag is crazy. All right.
Wait. Okay. So, I didn't have the original, but I had this version.
You can play this one on stream. Okay. My DMs with you are not
loading. Happening.
Discord. Hello. Oh, there we go. There we go.
I got it. Oh, it's a move file though. Gonna have to put it on
streamable. Hold on. I don't know why Chrome can't play move
files. That seems stupid. But he gets me fired up when he talks.
He's just like
I don't know. He's got like a political delivery to what he's
saying to where I feel like I got to get up in March. I have
a dream. Okay. So So the original was Okay, this is a good version.
I like this. The original was Tekon. The original was Tekton.
had someone edit uh on there instead cuz I thought it was I wasn't
even looking at that part of the screen. What the Oh, man. He
lost it. That is crazy.
Okay, Aiden. Aiden, which
which tech clip was it? What he that he's talking over? It was
just Tech Tone saying some random Wait, I think I know who tweeted
a hole. I think I gave you the original clip. Why is he like
jerking him off? He's just like when he talks I feel so motivated
because this guy like
this guy's like your like average like c righty centrist bro
knows nothing about politics just like likes Asmin Gold. Hold
on.
Know nothing about politics dude. I'm I'm I'm apolitical you
know. Oh my
just kidding. Oh the uh
listen this guy had a Ethan Klein video recently. This guy we
might need to get this guy in the Discord. Okay. The chipy guy.
Yeah, we might need to get the He has the strongest jawline I've
ever seen. Yeah, we need the We need the Easter Island statue
on the stream. Okay, we need him. Dude, he gets me fired up when
he talks. He's just like, okay, I don't know. He's got like a
political delivery to what he's saying where I feel like I got
to get up and march. He gets me. Imagine telling another man,
you get me fired up when you talk.
Can we hold on? What other political leader got people to stand
up and mar like is he not clearly thinking of is he not clearly
actually thinking like
what's worse is that is second rate as
was if it was between as gold and I'm going every time for real
can you play it one more time I just
hold on hold on hold on
right right that's That's our choice. That's our choice between
Golden between Tag and him. Okay. Every time. Dude, there's a
bit of one of his videos as well where he's talking about his
recent ban where he's like, um, he's like seething and he's like,
"Oh, yeah. I'm sure someone's quote tweeted this with dead."
Oh, yep. There it is. It's like,
you should be honored. You clearly already looked at the thread,
too.
Oh, god. Man,
he's the worst. All right, one more time. One more time. Dude,
he gets me fired up when he talks. He's just
I don't know. He's got like a political delivery to what he's
saying to where I feel like I got to get up in March. I have
a dream.
Enforce it. Thank you for giving me 1 million subs on YouTube.
I'm going to go get a golden retreat. I feel like the I have
a dream is like I guys, I was totally thinking of Martin Luther
King and not the other guy you're thinking of. I promise. Dude,
it's impossible not to
dying,
dude. This guy is like so pathetic. I like had to stop making
fun of him. It's like
it's so bad. You made fun of him too much. The Knox Israel debate
was the craziest thing when this guy had Knox come on and teach
him about Israel Palestine.
And Cheeto had Knucks on to teach him about
Oh my god, this was so good. You need to see this at some point,
man. Not just cuz I was involved, but I'm a narcissist. But a
Cheeto basically goes on to stream and talks about um Israel
Palestine. Oh no, no goes on to Cheio's stream and just like
basically spits like Israeli propaganda for like a full hour.
And then Cheeto does push back in a couple places, but he clearly
isn't quite equipped to do it. And then Cheeto came on my stream
like the next day and and spoke about it and it was just like
so funny. He was just like, "Yo, I'm trying to like um I'm trying
to like learn more about politics. I mean like Asmin go politics
now and I can't do the same thing." It's like oh no. Okay, so
this is what's happening, right? So Asmin Gold is like blown
up as a political commentator and now there you got all these
clones. It's like the moist critical politics. You got like Knucks
Tech Tone. I guess now a Cheeto is trying to position himself
in that like direction. Yeah. Yeah. Oh no. He's going to be he's
going to be uh skinwalking as gold.
I just Sorry. I had a seizure bro. My bad. My bad. Sorry. Sorry.
You know, the problem is is like I feel like so Asmin Gold like
the reason why he's popular is because he does fence it. He's
like middle of the road. He he tries to come across as very like
levelheaded,
you know, for dumbass. He just doesn't say anything. He just
never takes a position on anything. He like and whenever he does,
it blows up in his face massively. I totally understand why this
guy would say what he's saying right now is his approach to everything.
Yeah. I I I just feel like the problem is with the people that
try to clone him the hardest. like Nux and Techone,
they come off like way too aggressively but with the most positions
possible. Like they don't try to fence it as much. I could be
wrong with this, but this is just from what I've noticed. Very
briefly techone for sure. I would I don't want Teone 100%.
They got hard, but they just don't know where what they're doing,
you know? They all run from the debate. I don't know. It seems
like they don't understand what makes Asmin Gold popular and
so they just they copy his personality but they don't copy his
strategy
and uh they end up getting into way more trouble than Asmin Gold
does. Does Asmin Gold have like a a strategy? He just like just
like gives calculated in the sense of like he knows like just
how not to like get himself I mean with exception obviously to
when he was like Palestinians or animals or whatever when he
said that. Yeah, I feel like after that, you could be genocided.
I feel like Aspigold is like a Mr. Beast type of creator where
he's just very calculated in everything that he does or says
um to like avoid controversy. Is that not true? I don't think
to avoid controversy. I think he leans into controversy, but
he he is calculated in that he hasn't really taken a position
that's like uh that he can't fall back from and like make more
reasonable. M I I'd say he says things that are controversial
like his whole like oh I'd love to go I'd love to get some Pokeballs
and dress up like do an Ash Ketchum cosplay and go to the border
and catch some illegals. It's like like to a walk was it a had
a walk on like a tour with the border patrol, right? Like that
was pretty in like that was incendiary to some people, but he's
like off the right people, so he can't even really be criticized,
right? He off like people, so nobody's really going to criticize
Well, that's the beauty of politics is like you can just demonize
any of your critics as, oh, they're on the left and you know,
Jason
Knox clip I just sent you. This is like This guy is like so it's
unbelievable. This guy's like next
Okay. Oh god. This the file name is Nuxtaku is an Fslur, but
it's Nuaku is an Fslur bracket one bracket. So Queen's already
sent me this clip before to see about it. This is Was against
the murder of civilians. Civilians did die in his attacks, but
he was against the murder of civilians vehemently. That said,
that said, uh, there's some crazy going. Nelson Mandela would
slap the out of this guy. What? So, this guy, this guy was literally
like he was like the second in command basically of the ANC.
He was like he's like um
N Mandela's top guy and he's saying Nelson Mandela.
Nelson Mandela. Yeah, he was like one of the top guys and Nux
is just like confidently saying, "Yeah, Nandela hate this guy."
Just cuz uh Trump Trump awesome. Trump Trump's so based. It's
just like so I think Mandela chose him to run the ANC either
when he was imprisoned or like after he died. Like he he was
like the guy who's basically being groomed to be the leader of
the
Why is Nu talking making political content? I don't know. I don't
know. I have no idea why it Yeah. Wow. Yeah. Incredibly lucrative.
That's like literally he went from like 300 average viewers on
kick to like 2,000 average viewers on kick. He literally just
gripped towards Asmin Gold and Techone knowing knowing like both
of them. It's Does it have uh any relation to the Lollcon drama
or is this just like the natural arc you would have gone on anyway?
Like I I always wonder like did he just become like hyper political
and like super on the right to deflect from the criticism that
he got from everyone calling he was already kind of he was already
well in that trajectory by the time that [__] happened.
Yeah.
I think more
I mean he says his cousin died in October 7th right? His cousin
was in the IDF and died in October 7th or some so he rides very
hard for Israel and Trump. Yeah. I just uh he's just some dumbass
who makes like anime content, you know, like all of his content
has always been like the most low IQ slop,
you know, um of all time. You know, you know, like Twitch's hentai
song. Oh man, I think I've listened to that like a hundred times.
That's fire. That's fire.
It's so funny how it ends with uh Twitch, why did you ban Dr.
That's awesome. Ages really well, man. I wonder if he uh he probably
still agrees to that.
Some people are saying
the guy is like pretty corrupt. The serial ramophosa guy is actually
like pretty corrupt. Has had like some corruption
investigations now. Probably not as principled as he once was.
So there is Yeah, that's not what um you know is referring to
there. That was about the meeting where Trump saying that white
South African's been genocided.
This guy's like no. Yeah. This guy's like what what are you talking
about? What are you talking
Uh, can you do that accent a little harder? Can you go one more
time?
No, I can't. No, I can't do it on demand. Okay. All right.
Oh, it's the tweet.
I everyone who wrote me, I've had like hundreds of tweets sent
to me yesterday and today talking about how I am just like a
fallen off lol cow and stuff like this for all of the takes that
I'm saying on Ethan Klein. Meanwhile, Dioro goes live tonight,
says all of the takes that I said and all of all of a sudden
the tweet stopped. All of a sudden, the uh machine that was turned
on against me was uh shut off. It's almost like they're all total
bots that have been following someone who is essentially totally
willing to ride the wave as far as it will go until he starts
getting significant push back from people he can't ignore. Yeah,
it's just been nuts. Like my Twitter has just been a like landmine.
And this is not the I mean I tweeted like about Ethan Klein probably
like a week or two ago and it was the same thing where it's like
everybody was just on my ass. Except the difference is now it's
like you know Dioru goes live gives the sensible take of like
this is not doxing blah blah blah Hassan did not dox anyone and
now people who were like you don't get it you know what the worst
part is everyone was coping so hard by saying like well you don't
understand the main point is about how hypocritical Twitch is
and I'm like because if it was about Twitch's hypocrisy they
wouldn't be mad at Hassan directly right like well and they'd
trying to burn down YouTube over the Sniper Wolf thing still,
right? I think people just basically
This is not just Twitch. Like I think a part of it is definitely
Twitch, but a lot of it is Hassan. A lot of it is people looking
at what Hassan did and saying this is like horribly unethical.
This is doxing. He needs to be banned. A lot of it is thinly
veiled political motivations. Let's be serious.
Yes.
I I wish there was like like a large streamer that could stream
and like, you know, compete with, you know, these these these
freaks,
I wish there was like some sort of streamer that could do that.
I don't know. That's just me. I don't know. See where you're
coming from. How do you feel about covert white nationalism,
Ralph? As long as Nick Dioro stops being the top guy of commentary,
I could give two fist Listen,
resurrect that guy. Give him a GoPro. We'll be fine. Hey, we
bow to the Dawn. Don had a stunning performance tonight. We kneel.
He bow to the dude. He can't even look down at us when we bow.
Okay. His [__] Well, no, I don't think he did because
he not he not did along to the legal mindset video about doxing.
And that video is pretty because it imply he legal mindset tries
to make the case that basically people would have a course of
action, legal course of action against Twitch on the grounds
of um unfair enforcement of the toos. But so many people have
been banned for unfair enforcement of the to
on many platforms. I know for instance Mr. spoke to lawyers about
this and was planning he was trying to seek out a lawsuit if
he could. So people have seek this out before and no one's come
out with anything. You can't seem to hold these platforms to
their toss and say like oh you're being inconsistent cuz they
all say we'll dominate you for any reason. Yeah. They all put
in their toss that we get to make all decisions that and that's
and that's totally legitimate and that they're allowed to do
that. It seems that seems to be the case. They're allowed to
do that. So, you're completely on that, but for some reason,
Lady Boy Mindset, this complete lazy eyed loser, uh, goes out
on his channel every day, he's like, "Oh, actually, I think there's
a legal course of action against Twitch on the grounds of unfair
unfair termination. I think Nathan Bottle should sue Twitch."
He's unorically saying that right now. And then Nick Boring
along to his gab video on this. So, absolutely, it's not just
No, it's not. I agree. Nick absolutely pressed Dan and did a
good job pressing Dan. He did a good job pressing Dan the other
day as well. But Dan is an open already discredited liar. The
only people who are buying into what Dan says are the absolute
mindless drones who will follow the last thing they heard and
people who have a motivation to believe what Dan's saying. It
is completely worthless to push back against Dan when Nick is
still. And I just, you know, it's just the reality. He is riding
the wave as far as he can possibly take it and then taking the
tiniest steps back when he when he feels like okay maybe maybe
this is too far now maybe this is too far now there is no principle
guiding it and it's so blatantly obvious to anyone watching even
when he's talking about a non a non-disparagement agreement in
the context of the lawsuit he says he wouldn't want that to happen
that makes his job hard that would be gay but he stopped short
of saying this is against my principles I think that would be
an infringement on these people's free speech or anything significant
that actually lays down a belief like that and he absolutely
refuses to do this.
Where can I find uh your conversation with Dan? I want to watch
this like the one where
he's like openly
I think that's going to be a Jod somewhere. But he he will say
the quote is I believe he says I don't I don't say what's or
he says I care about winning or I say what I need to to win.
It's like he says that like repeatedly
um again and again. Yeah. Whenever he's whenever he's pressed
about stuff. And he said it to Nick as much, you know, tonight.
He like he went on Nick stream and while we impressed he just
says to Nick, "Yeah, I am." Yeah. I'm trying to win. It's like
he just says this. It's like the only people that are believing
him at this point are this like beef with Hassan. Is it just
because he's friends with Destiny or is it deeper than friends
with Destiny? Destiny got seemingly from their perspective unfairly
banned though. I don't know how true that is. um
that uh destiny that that Hassan has shouted on him for so long
and he sort of cut Dan off without speaking to him. So they just
[__] hate Asan. And then also Dan believes to some
extent I think he does actually believe there is anti-semitism
there to some extent and you know he loves the and loves Israel
and Assan's like the leading force against them or something.
Yeah. Yeah. Cuz I'd like to watch that and get caught up here
cuz I don't know too much about hold on then. No, no. I forgot
he said this with Really on the stream, too. I forgot he also
he was super zansed out. He had way too many sleeping meds before
he said this. He comes back, I think, later in this stream and
like corrects this, but this is like an opinion I feel like he
stated more than once. You know, it's sad because I've dedicated
the last like two weeks of my life basically to Steve's cause.
What? So, one, not like anti-semitism, but to [__]
with Twitch cuz they banned Destiny. Which one? You're talking
about the Twitch thing? Yeah, destroying Twitch. I thought it
was more of your thing than Why the do I care about Twitch? I'm
not banned there. I thought I thought you paired because they
were like anti-Semitic and being weird. No, it's just fun. Oh,
okay. I Yeah. So, okay. So, this is actually true. I mean, that's
this isn't the clip we're talking about. He had an explicit.
This is true. This is a separate thing. Dan really the thing
that is actually driving him at his core is he just wants to
be a leader of like a raid online. He just likes like doing raids
and brigading. He just like he just he just wants to be that
guy. He just wants to go around rallying the troops and attacking
people and feeling like he's on top that just like a pure anim
animalistic like he is just like an old dude around the internet
and trying to feel cool. No, it's like an old dude who like gets
off on feeling cool online.
I like him in that case. I have no issues with him. He's cool.
Yeah. I I always say I don't mind Dan because he is just an open
liar and it's like I don't have to even It's like there's no
point even
like condemning him because it's like I mean what what what do
you say? Like he's he's an open liar. Is that what Tommy said
about you? He respects your open lie openly. Yeah. But I don't
but I'm not actually like that. I'm not actually a liar and I
don't actually go around saying yeah I just lie. Yeah, I just
lie. and does and that's like there's no point even combating
him at that point, right? Yeah. It's just kind of a waste of
time. He's just Well, he's basically admitting he's a troll,
you know? Yeah. It's like if you engage, you're Yeah. You have
to engage with people that are repeating he's saying I'm curious
to see uh his show with Willie Mac because I know they're doing
that weekly now.
I wonder if Willy M does he do him have him and Dan interacted
at all? when he went to Destiny's house, they would have interacted
a lot. Well, yeah, I guess uh personally or what IRL. I'm just
curious like on the internet like have they done much? It seems
like he's pretty desperate to get out of the Destiny circle
cuz he's trying to do the show with Willie. He's trying to do
a show with Nick. It seems like he's he does he does a show with
uh Techone and uh Nucks, doesn't he? Or is that Well, he did
like one episode, I think. One one show. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I
can think. What do you think of the disturbing pattern that's
coming out, Auggie, of um everybody who needs to oppose?
Yeah. All the Levians being against Asan. Okay.
We got Techone. We got Lady Boy Minds.
Cameron F305. Techone.
It's a prolific Destiny. It's a prolific group. We've got Yeah.
I'm waiting for Dr. Disrespect to jump in. You know, Diddy Chat
Dan. We got Diddy Cat Dan is against Hassan.
Yeah, it seems like the Hassan Grips is like I've been making
videos just hating Hassan since like 2019.
I've been making as many videos hating on Hassan as I've had
videos hating on Ethan Klein. Like Hassan has always been like
the number one of the biggest targets
uh not just amongst the commenter community, but just like a
lot of people just that are cool like understand that Hassan
is terrible. And now it just feels too cheap.
It's just like it's fun when it's like um this guy's like a piece
of Nepo baby who nobody's calling him out. Yeah. And no one's
calling him out. And it's like the criticisms are like Yeah.
They're like pretty um scathing to like credibility and stuff,
but they're not like this guy needs to be put in jail
or something like that, you know? Like but now it's at the point
where everything is like he he's like a terrorist. people call
would just call him a terrorist. They would just do that. Well,
they make him sound cool when they
happens being cool and you start you can start editing him dancing
to like um NH and it's like funny it's like okay this guy's like
a base like leftist Nazi that was awesome. Yeah. It's like they're
missing the target. It's like you know instead of cuz before
the criticisms that he's gay, he lies. he's insecure as, you
know, like Desi exposed his insecurity of like how poor he performs
in debates and stuff like that. It was all like just like biting
criticisms that were not many people were making and it was kind
of like a fun thing to [__] on him over. And now
he still is that. Yeah, I'm not saying he's not still that. You
know, don't get me wrong, he's not as cool as what people make
him out to be today, right? He obviously is still like a complete
nutcase, at least from what I've seen. But yeah, the whole campaign
against him, it just seems like too easy of a grift for people,
especially creators like Mudahar,
you know, or a KN who have been kind of like disgraced in a major
way. It's just kind of easy for them to jump onto this whole
brigade and make all these like moralizing stupid arguments that
also serve like some like the worst like types of areas of the
internet like the ADL, you know. Yep. Exactly. It's like and
when you're like literally getting on people are getting on stream
every day and they're making the exact arguments the ADL are
making saying it's anti-semitic and harmful what Hassan's doing
and then and then saying oh what oh I don't support the ADL I
don't support the ADL so
everyone right up to you've been walking people right up to the
line walked right up to the line of Han needs to be completely
wiped out face of earth needs to be put in prison for being antiic
but just dropped at the end and you're saying I don't support
the ADL why don't you support the ADL You've made the entire
argument. All the all the premises are there. The conclusion
would seem to follow. Why do you not just support the ADL? Like
keep screaming that this guy's a harmful anti anti-semite that
needs to be put in jail. That's what
it's like it has to be like I don't like the ADL, but I agree
with them on Hassan. But it's like, well then when you question
it, well, why do you agree with them on Hassan? You agree with
them on Assan because of their reasoning and their logic that
you claim to be against in the first place, right? It's like
it's not just like, oh, I think Assan's gay and the ADL thinks
he's gay and I like the I like their take on H. It's like, no,
no, no, no. Nobody can have that position, you know? Yeah. They
repeat the talking points,
but
I don't know. I It's just a situation where I'm still like I'm
not like pro- Hassan by any means whatsoever. I I'm anti- everyone.
I'm sick of these uh
I'm sick I'm sick of this stupid war dictating all the content.
You know what I mean? Everyone's just lost their minds. Why can't
you just be a hater? Why can't you just be against them all?
What's wrong with like uh political nihilism? You know, what's
wrong with just not even political, what's wrong with just hating
people, right? Can't you just hate them all?
Can't you just be and I said this before like a few weeks ago
when I called in the stream, but it's like, isn't that the most
fun position when everybody involved
is a up and you can just go at them all? Why does it have to
be a team? Uh, it can be, but I think probably I mean that's
a that is the most fun, but also if one of them is worse, you
probably should be able to perceive that and call it out as worse,
right? I honestly can't tell which one's worse. I don't know
who in this situ Well, between Ethan and and Hassan, you mean?
Yeah. I I really can't tell. As an
I would probably still say Hassan, but as like a system, I think
it's it's starting the Ethan side's starting to get up there.
like it's like the the system that's for I feel like it started
off so well like like you know I watched Continent I agreed with
it you know I didn't see anything wrong there or whatever I a
lot of like H3 the H3 podcast segments on Hassan I thought were
fire but in the last few months it's like they got tired of winning
and they just decided to become
you know and they decided to just up the ante like 10 million
degrees
and now
or maybe they're just exposing exposing themselves for being
part of like a political machine, not necessarily just people
that have like a problem with what Hassan does, but rather like
people that are serving a devious system.
But I don't know. I don't know what it is. But,
you know, I can't sit here and say that I'm going to like
necessarily disagree with everything Ethan says about Hassan
in the future. You know what I mean? He might say plenty of bay
about Hassan. I don't know. You know, Hassan's a maniac, but
I'm just saying it's like they're both they both got something
wrong with them. I don't know if that's like Fin City or uh if
that's too much of a take, but they both got something wrong
with them. And I think it's just fun to hate on them both. I
think that's where most people should be. Oh, I just had my muted.
I was literally I was literally responding to Augie. [__]
[__] I was responding to Auggie totally. I was responding
to Auggie totally there. And I like Everybody was silent. Everybody
was silent. So, I just uh So, I just assumed people were listening.
I just assumed people were listening cuz everybody was like,
"God damn it." Nice. Me. Okay. Uh what was I saying? Oh, I totally
agree that like Hassan is uh he's But it's so weird when people
are like, "Oh, he's a threat to Democratic party. He's going
to like actually give us like the Trump dynasty. Literally the
Trump family dynasty. We're going to get every Trump for like
the next 30 years. We're just going to have a Trump as president
of the United States because of Assam." It's like, "No, we're
not. No. No. He's not that threatening. He's not that scary.
I don't know. It's It's shocking. I was also trying to see to
find this clip right here for us. This was the the podcast we
were talking about. And Dan goes on to talk about why he basically
kind of like how he basically kind of justifies, you know, not
being totally honest. And I think he says, "I'm honest about
my dishonesty." I think that's what this is. But I was also I
was trying to read the transcript. I would say also, sorry, man.
I uh I muted my mic for two seconds and left it muted. try to
mute it for two seconds for longer. You know, another important
thing is like I saw Hassan go on a rant last night where he was
going on and on about context and how he was so donest and if
he did anything that was dishonest, his audience would hold the
speed to the fire. Of course not. But that's part of the game.
I expect you to say it. So the difference is that and I think
people give me a lot of for this because I say it whereas other
people lie about it. Um I will uh make you look as bad as possible
because you're a bad person and there's enough source material
to do it. I don't feel bad about taking a screenshot of the homepage
and putting it on my uh Twitter feed because you are doing the
same thing. You just you're more cy about it, right? Like you
want to talk about that happened in 2009 when one of my 30 investors
like like this this is insane. You went to a diddy party. Like
I'm fine. So, okay. It's like uh it's like transparently like
oh your people make fun of me for tiny chat being like a grooming
ground and you make fun of me for getting money from Diddy for
tiny chat and so I'm going to try to destroy you and by any means
necessary is like the general idea he's going with here. So the
diddy party thing it I'm assuming that didn't happen like
I missed that one. So Hassan
was at Coachella high on mushrooms and apparently he he walked
into a tent or he went to he was planning to go to a tent where
there's a Diddy like party right at Coachella and then I think
he says like I saw a girl dancing in a video that looked like
way too young and he basically implies it weirded him out and
he left.
Okay, what's the uh problem there? There is no problem. But if
you just say Hassan went to a diddy party
basically implies something weird happened, right? Yeah. It's
like one of those li where it's like well technically that I
guess did happen sort of but he left out of disgust. I I don't
know unless you're saying that he lied and there is a whole thing
of like
the diddy party at Coachella that's in the tent isn't like the
diddy party freak off lawsuit like there's crazy trafficking
happening everywhere. Like that's not Yeah. The same thing like
this is like a relatively public thing that people can wander
into defending it. It's like it's like it's funny when you just
say it as like a kind of kind of a joke like tongue and cheek
like you into a dy. Yeah. Like Destiny's an or Yeah, exactly.
But it's when you're like no this let's go to a daddy party.
This guy's doing weird with kids and like that. It's like okay
well now you're actually arguing him, right? Yeah. Be like if
Juck was responding to Destiny's like this guy who's literally
a is now saying that Yeah. Yeah. You just I mean Yeah. Basically,
if somebody presses you on something in some way and you like
just double down on it, like that's your position. And you can't
really get away from like holding that as a position. And Dan
will double down on how bad these things are. He literally did
this one, the Diddy Party one with Deorio on not the past stream,
but the one before that. It's just so stupid. It's just giving
Hassan ammunition to just be like, "These people are just dishonestly
trying to ruin my life, blah blah blah." And then when he lays
out like what they're doing, like lying that he's like a diddy
party attender or a doxer or something like that, uh it just
is so meaningless. Like why
do this? Look who he's on the podcast with. Look who he's on
the podcast with. Like [__] Knox the lollycon and
tactone the alleged an
So what what's the optics here? What are the optics here? It's
like, yeah, Dan, the guy received funding from Diddy, the lollycon,
and the alleged sit around talking about how Hassan's terrible
for going to a relatively public party at Coachella.
Yeah. The funny thing about this is that I think Dan
like trying to kids is one of the only banned memes ever for
like an orbiter in Destiny's community where like they just outright
banned people this from making
Uh, are we going to do Dan went to Dan had a weird incident in
Hawaii? And as Yes. As a longtime Destiny watcher, as a longtime
Destiny viewer, I recall Hawaii holiday, the Hawaii vacation
with Dan Sman, Mr. Mutton and Destiny and Molina where they went
to Hawaii and there was something that happened that I don't
know whether it was ever disclosed to the public where they all
started Dan was a pedophile basically and then Dan starts sensitive
about it and it became
or something
his he did start a company that took seed funding from a comp
from like a fund that took money from data yourself like he actually
got money from data not directly, like he didn't go seek it out,
but like his company did get funded by Diddy. The guy wasn't
a massive like funer either. And then that platform was then
used. I think there's a clip of Diddy hitting on an underage
girl on the platform or a young girl on the platform. And it
was just generally there are stories of people getting like kind
of groomed on that platform as
He ran a chat or whatever. Yeah, he ran like basically like a
chat roulette kind of thing. Tiny chat.
Tiny chat. Wow. Okay. Interesting.
Um, I think the truth of that I think the truth of that Hawaii
story is like kind of out there. Apparently got discussed on
a phone call. I can't remember. It It's like fairly innocuous.
I think
like I don't know if it was I think it's funny when it's very
ambiguous.
I know. I think then screws himself by allowing it to be ambiguous
kind of. So
that's funny.
I think it was kind of innocuous. Yeah. but
should leave it ambiguous cuz he wants to leave Hassan going
to a brothel that got raided by the I've heard Hassan say that
you know say essentially that he left he said yeah it was like
weird as [__] or whatever um I've never I've never
heard Dan the other Dan has to explain what happened in Hawaii
beat the allegation answers right now what do you guys think
of Dan like do you hate him do you like him like what is your
I like him I like him part it's hard to hate him because he is
transparent that he is going to do whatever he can. Like if you
go against him, he's going to do whatever he can to destroy you
and he'll be like as underhanded as he has to and he'll tell
that to your fa he'll tell that to you to your face. I mean,
is it hard to hate a guy that's that openly
malicious? I feel like it's pretty easy to hate somebody that's
like that. Is it just cuz he's like funny or something? Cuz again,
I don't really know too much about him. Well, I think for Quean
it like I can't really speak for myself because I don't want
to. But for Quumman, I think he's just generally like scared
that this guy will dox and try to kill him and soqu I mean that's
that's reasonable. That's that's you know, you're right. I I
like Dan, too. No, that's reasonable. No, it's DG brain rot.
Like literally Dan never shows up in the server. Once the JTO
allegations drop, this guy was in the server in VC. I don't know
why JTock still likes this guy.
I went into that VC and started asking him why he won't talk
to Bes. I like that. I like that. I think that's cool. Yeah.
Okay.
I do too. And I am pro. He has he has an endearing uh you know
lovable old old man personality if you know what I mean. Like
Yeah. He's like a like a uncle really desperate to be cool you
know. So he's like successful boomer that wasn't cool in high
school. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Yes. He's successful Tommy C. That's
what you're saying. If he wasn't if he didn't make the money
he does he his wife could take care of him. Yes. His wife could
support him. He's successful.
Sober Tommy C is what you're saying. Not sober. Not sober. Not
sober. Okay. Damn.
This is literally a This is literally like a custommade bar back
here that keeps his alcohol cold. Yeah. This is his version of
the arcade cabinets and pinball machines. Okay. That's awesome.
It is pretty cool. This room is pretty cool. Dan does some pretty
cool things.
Yeah. Yeah. I'll sit here and say, you know, I actually am pro-
Israel in the war. So,
You're an ethnationalist and you support ethnational states pursuing
their agendas.
Yeah, I get it. I understand
there. Hold on. Uh, that actually just reminded me.
Oh, hold on. Where was it? Hold on. I'll find it. I don't want
to give it away.
I swear to God. It's a clip from
Fuentes. Oh, here it is. Here it is.
You're going to play the him siding with the clip. Yes. Yes.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Was necessary because they chanted death
to America. I sent your clip and Timothy Bordon clips on Zionism.
What should I do at my dad? Benny Johnson is gay. Enjoy your
4th of July. Why? Why? Why are we here? Is it just to suffer?
Is it just so that we can be tortured to death by idiots? So
we could just be tortured to death by the goyam.
Why? Okay, I'm like two seconds out from just joining the at
this point. Like I want to oppress you with them at this point.
It's like I started out like the Jews are oppressing us, then
it's like no, no, the are oppressing all of you. Maybe I need
to help them. Maybe I need to enhance that. Maybe just how like
the kings of Europe used to hire the torture their own people,
maybe the will hire and that be something.
It's still an option. It's always an option. Let's just say let's
put that on the back burner. Let's just say that's plan B. We
get like his uh his like Buffalo Ranch clip, his like barbecue
clip. really just rants about barbecue food. If anybody could
find that one, that is the one I want next. Okay, if somebody
finds it, I'll play it. Love when he takes the no talk talk from
no more.
Just push your You die is real. You do nothing.
I have it.
So good.
Closing up some of these tabs. Never mind. Don't need to close
that tab. That tab can stay open. Oh, I'm not I'm probably not
going to splunk through this VOD anymore right now with so many
people here. But oh boy, where did Aiden go? Why did Aiden just
peace out? What is he doing? Aiden just joins these calls and
just dips in like two minutes. He doesn't stay for the long haul.
Yeah, I don't know. I don't know what that is. What the heck,
man? He likes to listen what's what's being said so he can copy
a take for later.
True. True. Yeah, it is kind of a piece of [__] I'm
not going to lie. I follow that guy. Okay. Kill. I'm not even
joking, dude. Like, I've been friends with this guy since like
2018.
His streams for the last year
have just been [__] Auggie this community. Everything
about RFC. I hope RFC burns. I hope RFC dies.
And for years, he's always told me how I saved his life and how
I was like an amazing figure to him and how my community gave
him a purpose and a home. And yet on stream, he acts like, you
know, I'm like just like the biggest piece of [__]
of all time. It It really does make me violently angry towards
these people. Is that why he was gay as a teenager? Yeah. Is
that the community that his came from? He was a No, I can't say
I could I could understand where the hatred would come from probably.
No, no, no, no. That was not from my community. We actually were
working on getting him fixed. I was in contact with Milo Yiannopoulos.
We were going to get him sent. He was going to be the first person
sent to Milo's conversion camp. He was going to have a a male
mentorship with Mil with Milo, right? Milo's like a conver straight
conversion therapy camp. We were going to get him sent to that.
um would be kind of like a priest and he would be a young boy.
Well, I actually had Aiden going to uh Catholic church like he
was actually like con in the process of converting and then he
abandoned all of that to turn on me. So, it was a sad thing.
We were trying to get him fixed but unlucky.
Yeah. I just think he needs to stop disrespecting me so much.
It's kind of disgusting. Yeah. Whatever Tyrone did to him like
back in 2016 was really This guy's name really Tyrone. I mean,
if you want to likes black dates, black dates. Listen, I don't
I'm
despite what Aiden says about me, I'm not going to reveal any
private information about him like that. You know, he's welcome
to tell his own
So, if you're not looking into any of Tommy C stuff, or you just
uh I know the basics of it. I It got into like a lot of like
convolute. I saw the first video and like the first stream and
a bit of Chad Logic's response, but like the eight billion streams
after that I didn't look at and then uh Aiden's calling and stuff
like that. It just seems like a I don't really know what it seems
like a disaster, Chief. Yeah, I don't really know either to be
honest with you. I uh
I I think he I mean he probably
So you didn't see uh when Willie was on there the other day about
the Jook stuff? No, I didn't watch that at all. Oh, dude, it's
so bad. It's so
they are just doing like a victory lap of like, oh yeah, this
makes Destiny look so good. Like this is Were they really saying
that? Come on. I just talked to Willie the other night. I I don't
want to. You need a time stamp? I'll throw it up right now. I
don't have time. Let me let me analyze this. Yeah. Yeah. He did
like stream. He did like a whole stream. Pull up the Tommy C
stream. Pull up the Tommy stream. Let's do it. Let's do it. Well,
look, if they're just clowning on you, that's base. But it's
like if they're saying Destiny Yeah. Yeah, if they're saying
Destiny vindicated, I take an I don't I don't I don't know if
vindicated it's like vindicated. I think they say this makes
Destiny look so good. Like, you know, it's basically being like
um it's doing the game where you talk about optics all the time.
You say this makes this person look so good, you know, but don't
don't you say like, oh, what they did is still really really
terrible and I hate him. Listen, I need to hear from their words.
You guys are all dishonest actors who are looking to destroy
one of my all of my friends to be honest with you. And so I need
They want him They want him dead. Exactly. Aiden was in here
talking about how he wants Tommy sees friends on him and him
in the streets. It was disgusting to hear that. So, I need to
hear from their words. This is a pretty Yeah, the the Anyway,
the main reason I brought this up, I just I finished saying this
was um that Willie Mack comes on and basically says there's like
chatters antagonizing them about the Chud stuff. Yeah. And uh
Willie basically starts uh starts lashing out. He seems a bit
he seems a bit touchy and uh he starts going this chat and he's
like why do you think Tommy's saying all that stuff about what
people are saying behind the scenes? You think he's just making
that up? No, obviously people saying that stuff like basically
just like going no charge really is a piece of like just backing
it all up and yeah
it's very uh very cringe. Interesting. Quean fan is a big donator
here. I'm just looking. You just scan through the bot. I'm guessing
is Willie going to show up on stream? Is he going to show up
like in a Discord call or something? No, I don't know if he's
shown on screen when he's there.
Okay, this is a pretty funny meme. You got to admit the thumbnail
is pretty good, right? What was the thumbnail? I didn't see it.
Or not the thumbnail, but just the little image, the meme that
he has of you. Just like Destiny. Uh,
no. I like genuinely really care about this person. I don't find
that funny. But like I don't criticize anybody's ability to do
to, you know, it's like a personal thing. Um, I don't criticize
anybody's like you want to make your jokes. I get it. It's fine.
I'm not gonna like get mad at you. It's like a personal thing,
but it's fine. I just thought it was ridiculous and uh and very
out there. It's Yeah, it's honestly I've got no I would never
be like angry at Tommy for it's fine. It's on Twitter. Laughing
my Bob J face talk was a dating cherry uh to get I'm going to
I'm going to go ahead and find where this Willie call is. You
got any idea where it is?
That was a problematic tuned in and out live. So I I haven't
marked out any time. Uh let's see.
Crashing crashing out. If you search and now we're crashing.
So search um
you see was crashing out or something like that. Making stuff.
Making making that up. Destiny's making that up entirely. And
the thing you did reach out to me to I basically said Destiny's
making No. No. Oh, sorry. I'm talking about the Chud stuff. I'm
talking about the Ch. I don't know if you're looking for the
Destiny stuff.
I'm just looking for Yeah, sorry. Chud wasn't fair to him situation.
Um Oh, 14821. Thank you. Says what you Oh, Jesus Christ. You
would a YouTuber in the UK thing.
I thought I was irrelevant. First of all, second of all, if you
had a friend, you wouldn't be here. You would be doing something
else. You know why? Cuz you'd have a friend. So, have a good
day. talk. They're like yelling saying that like Willie sports
the ch to does Willie support the chud hate? Look, dude, if you
when Tommy's stating these positions where he goes Willie was
annoyed at this or Tom was annoyed at this or Nick was annoyed
with this, you think he's just making it up or you think people
have said that?
Come on, boys. Think you got this. I got full faith in you. I
don't know everything Tommy Hold on. No, I know everything Tommy's
said. All right. So, I don't I won't want to say I support everything
because I don't know the stuff he said related to me. Yeah, he's
heard it from me just like he's
you think I'm not talking to anybody. Like I I mean, are we serious?
They think I'm not talking to anybody. They think I just came
out of this out of nowhere.
This isn't it?
Just revealed this guy like sharing like details of your private
chat on stream and you just
took it this long to cosign it. Isn't this just weird behavior?
I think yeah, it's weird that they just wear their opinions like
over I think it's to I think it's totally embarrassing that Tommy
Sue did this gay bit in one of his live streams. He's like, "Oh,
Queen is like Ch's bad empanada."
And it's like he Tommy is literally like total Shabascoy attack
dog for
Nick, Willie, and Tom right now. like just total like literally
doing the work going and making himself look stupid on complaints
that they shouldn't even be upset about in the first place if
they went total things against uh to to go and cry about this
in public because they don't want to torch them their own reputations
doing it. They don't want to look they don't want to go against
you think like they're ordering Tommy to uh go on the attack
or this is like something Tommy's doing and they're venting to
him to know Tommy's enough to go do it. Yeah, they're venting
to him and then Tommy goes out and does it. Nick's not saying,
"Oh yeah, Tommy's being retired here. Obviously, I had an issue
with this, but it's not that f it's not that big of a deal."
Like, Tommy's being blown out proportion. Tom's not saying that.
And Willie is explicitly supporting it. So, he's doing the exact
like thing that that he accused me of doing for Chard, which
is going out and saying the opinion that the other people are
too scared to say, that are going out and, you know, going extreme
and snaking his friends so that he doesn't have to. That's literally
what Tommy's doing.
Yeah. Yeah. Tommy's sort of like the uh battering ram in this
community, I guess, is that he like goes live with like because
like I feel like Tommy's in a position right now where he doesn't
really super care about his channel or moving forward. I mean,
he's made probably like 20 different streams talking about wanting
to quit YouTube and stuff like this. And you know, so he's at
a point where his he doesn't really care anymore. So he's willing
to sort of be like this like batter ram of like where he just
has the takes of like whatever the I want to say like I'll just
throw them out there no matter how but it's not justified I'll
be right it's not what he wants to say. It' be one thing if it
was what he wants to say but he's doing the [__]
work for other people.
Well, I think he shares their opinions greatly because like
I let's be honest, I think out of all of the guys that uh you
know, y'all have given Willie a lot of y'all given Tommy a lot
of y'all have been given Nick some some amount of, right? I think
y'all have gone at Tommy C the hardest, right? So, he probably
has the most anger
towards you guys out of everyone. Is that fair to say? I have
literally never mentioned this before. Then why is that anger
at Chud, right? It's is like this is about Chud, right? See,
I don't understand why it was about Chud. I feel like this his
war should have been focused on you because you've been the most
Well, just because you've been like the most vocally against
him. I don't think Chud Chud's barely said about Tommy. See,
at least from what I've seen. Well, he did responses to the streams,
but yeah. Well, yeah, he did like a couple like coverages of
Tommy, but even then, like I I never saw Chud like going at Tommy,
whereas you were going at Tommy like every day for like a month.
Uh, so I feel like if Tommy was to wage this style of war, it
would make more sense to go at you. Yeah, but I think it's um
like a cuz I feel like a lot of it is about me, but it's like
it's definitely about you, Sean. You've you've betrayed you've
betrayed us by letting this guy do this and and not is the actual
betrayal here. Yeah. Yeah. I I I don't I really don't understand
that side of his argument because it's like to me just go after
the person that if you believe somebody is dishonestly attacking
you, go after that person. Like I guess it's like what is Chud's
what is the expectation on Chud to DM you every day and be like
stop doing that. You know, that's the part of the argument that
I don't understand. So yeah, I I just like aside from like um
Ch like blacklisting me, like cutting cutting me off of coming
on stream and raids and all that. It's like if Chud says, "Oh,
I think you're going too far there." It's like I might consider
it as like a thing, but it's not going to like make me stop.
You know, if Ch had said, I think you should stop going after
Tommy C. I probably would. I'm waging on dangerous waters here
right now. I can feel the pressure. Yeah, you are. You're tread
lightly, Yogi. Okay, man. You haven't streamed in a while. You're
you're you're uh you're not really uh in a position to be talking
this way. Okay. If they pull my support, I'm you guys know this,
right? Like
next Tommy C stream, Augie's been DMing me some things and he
hate the screaming guy, too. Oh no,
it's over. You know, I think we suddenly started launching a
bunch of vicious attacks on Nick while Ogie was sitting there
was I think I was really out of line. I think I think Ougi is
kind of betraying Nick by by not standing up to him there. Actually,
that's Tommy saying that's Tommy say like Nick's I stand by.
I am I die for the Adon. Okay.
I am loyal to uh Dioro and the Cabal. But no, I mean seriously
though, like yeah, I just I I feel like when it came to Thomas'
original points against Chud, I guess the points that I do agree
with is that like when it comes like the audience captured point,
that's probably true. Although I would say I think everyone is
audience captured to some extent. I mean, I think we're all influenced
by our chats to like a much larger degree than we would like
to admit. You know, nobody wants to go live and have the whole
chat full of people calling you a
and somebody who's just missing the point and stuff like that,
right? It feels uncomfortable. I think as a streamer, you want
everybody on your side. So, you're obviously going to want to
maintain that,
you know? So, I think everyone's audience captured to some extent.
Maybe you could make that argument with Chud because I think
the problem is is that there's a large community. Y'all's community.
I say y'all's community. I'm just grouping everybody into this
giant category. Who knows if they actually agree with each other
or not, but like the whole like idea of like the spicy chat community.
I think there's a lot of people in yell chat that want blood.
They want commentary and you guys to go at each other. They want
war. They want, they demand a lock, daily alocking of Dioro.
They demand, you know, a fight. And I don't necessarily see you
guys wanting to do that. I say you guys like I'm talking like
to you, Jtock, and Queen. I don't really see you guys as like
super wanting to do that, but you are willing to be critical.
And there is a different there is a different culture when it
comes to like cuz we come from like an older generation of YouTube
where it's like it's sort it is a click you know what I mean
it is sort of like if you are going hard on your buddy that is
seen as like almost like a declaration of war you know and I
feel like it's like an old whereas with you guys you guys are
just brutal to each other like you know I've seen Chud go into
you I've seen you guys go into each other and stuff like that
um you guys are a lot more brutal each other you come from this
sort of like Destiny community where it's like everyone it is
like that is the content is everyone fighting each other whereas
in the commentary community it is seen as like you know it is
a much more friendlier place until you are seen as like just
like an irredeemable piece of like Boax or tipster or flamingo
or somebody like that. So it's a clash yeah it's a clash of cultures.
Uh it's a clash it's it's two different communities of the internet.
It's two different times of the internet that are all coming
at each other's throats, right? And there's a lot of that going
on there.
And I think uh everyone just needs to calm the down just a little
bit and recognize like when I was doing RC Mania, you know, Chud
was like ripping into me, you know what I mean? But I didn't
care about that. You know what I mean? Like
did it piss me off a little bit? Sure. Right. But it's like we
were we we took what Chud was saying and we turned it on him.
and we were on him and stuff like that and it was just content
at the end of the day. You know what I mean? I still like Chud.
I think he's great. I think he does a great show. And I didn't
view what Chud was saying about me as like indicative that, oh,
he's my enemy now. Oh, he's going after me. He hates me. He doesn't
like me anymore. Or like, oh, he's looking for a chance to really
get me. This was just the way he wants me to lose my audience.
He wants me to lose my career. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. It's like
I just looked at it as just he was he was busting my balls and
we busted his balls back and that's just how content is done.
That's what makes content interesting is people see like this
little like beef or whatever, right? But it's not really that
serious. People see Chud throw shots at me, they see me throw
shots back at him, but it's not like this big deal where it's
like, oh, this is, you know, this is now a war and Chud is looking
to kill me and stuff like that. I feel like everyone needs to
just calm the down. But the problem is is that, you know, there
is a lot of paranoia going on these communities.
Yes, everyone's making too much money and it's made people a
little bit sensitive. I think a little bit over the Yeah. on
edge.
Those uh those comments from like Chud, those are like actually
really important by the way because that's what prevents you
from riding the wave for too long, right? If somebody can like
feel criticism and feel comfortable going like, "Oh, Nicholas
Doro is like riding Ethan's like right just as a jab." That's
what makes you kind of click in, be a little self-conscious,
and go, "Oh, wait. Maybe I'm going a little too far here." And
when you don't have that at all, like that's what causes you
to go like way off the rails sometimes. I think you guys are
like I think look, I'm going to do a little bit of oldfashioned
sweeping. I think you guys are a little bit too You guys think
Nick Dioro and when I say you guys, I'm talking mostly to the
chat. But I think like a lot of you guys think Nick Dioro is
a lot more and sold on his positions than he really is. Like
when he goes live tonight and in the doxing narrative, I was
like, "Yes, here we go." Right. But I think a lot of people were
surprised to hear him say that and to me it would be genuinely
shocking uh if Dior
no but we are so far past that because it's been
it's so blatant when people are buying in wholesale Nick like
it's it's not even Nick said Ethan is my attack dog. I like Ethan
when he's just fighting my enemies. Nick said this CPS call will
justify everything Ethan does for months. Ethan can go so far
because of this CPS call and then every time something's brought
up my CPS snark skulls from him every time blaming attributing
bad panada and denims and snark as all one entity and blaming
the CPS calling them with no evidence.
A standard that would never have been held with with careful
farms. But like those names you brought up like Ban Emp was the
guy that made the video with the narrative that Ethan's like
abusing his children basically. But you can't. Yes. Yes. But
we would usually So bad empanada you can say bad empanada made
a bad faith malicious video that spins Ethan as someone who has
a [__] covered house. Fair enough. Reasonable criticism.
You can say Denims
uh did not uh sufficiently push back when she when she watched
the video. Question was just like reasonable criticism. totally
reasonable criticism and you can say
seemingly maliciously called the called CPS on Ethan and it's
probably as a result of what they saw online. Okay, this is these
points are all reasonable. Now it becomes unreasonable is when
you start saying yeah these people they got the CPS called on
Ethan
Denims didn't get the CPS D didn't get CPS called Ethan. She
doesn't bear responsibility for some idiot going and doing that.
We would never hold that standard in any other drama ever. Keeles,
Brianna Woo, Game Against [__] what whatever it whatever
it is, we would never ever ever have held that standard. And
Nick has
pushed that the whole time. And he was sitting there pulling
up a drawing of Ethan holding skulls that was on the H3 Snark
subreddit. And he's sitting there looking at this going, "Oh
my, this is disgusting. These people are insane. This is disgusting.
These people are insane. There's the Nazi sword where he's saying
it's a dog whistle. It's an intentional dog whistle. It's like
Ethan only started pushing that after Nick bought bought into
it. Ethan's crew walked him back on the initial episode. Nick
acknowledges that Ethan is watching his show and that Ethan he's
like I think I'm getting messages to Ethan. He says this show
on stream. it the there is an open coordination
that is happening where standards have been completely dropped,
principles have been completely dropped. Yeah. And insane has
been pushed through. So we are so far past the point of oh Nick
had a base take tonight. No, I I agree. It's not like a Nick,
you've got to die for this. But holy [__] you have
to acknowledge I've let my principal slip. I can't I You know
what? If I could do some coverage again, I probably should have
done it better. I was kind of blinded. So, there's got to be
something cuz it's crazy. Like, it is so blatant. And like I
feel like, you know, I'm sitting here ranting a little bit, but
it it I can I can lay out very clearly. I feel like how this
the standards have changed, where the points of difference are,
where the sudden contradictions are. But all that is done is
CPS goals, they would do it to us. They would do it to us. At
that point, that's just no bad tactics, only bad targets and
no criticism of Ethan either. Like when Ethan says Denims did
CPS, I don't know where the where was like the the threads of
him people just being like, "What the [__] are you
talking about?" Right. It's not just like allowing attacks back
on Denims. It's like there's no criticism of Ethan at all. Anyway,
I just want to add that in right at the end.
Yeah. I mean, I feel like, you know, with denims or whatever.
I like she watched the video. She was very uncritical.
I don't even know how much commentary she gave over it. She might
have given a lot. I didn't watch her coverage of the bad empanada
video, but you know, she played that video. Her whole chat, well,
maybe just to say whole chat, but like a lot of her chat was
saying like, "Holy, this is crazy. Somebody needs to call CPS
or whatever." Right? If I was watching a video and for some reason
my whole chat was spamming like we need to dox this guy or something
like that, right? I feel like I would at some point notice like
the fact that my entire chat is But that's not the case. That's
not the case. That's That's a But that's not the case. That's
a complete lie that they've all pushed, Ogie. That is a complete
lie they have all pushed. Denims literally did a response video
that completely debunks this entire thing where she shows literally
the percentage of chat messages that were mentioning CPS within
a certain time. The way that video was made is it was not just
a cut out of her chat that is slowed down and slowly scrolled.
It is specifically filtered to only include the CPS and kids
messages. Mhm. It has been pushed as Oh, you can filter a Twitch
chat to only show the logs have been exported and someone searched
it. Yeah. And I think someone just built like an HTML thing that
would take the the transcript and like scroll it so it still
looks like a Okay, that's evil then if that if that happened.
You know what? Do you know what Nick said? You know what Nick
said about that Denim's video? He said, "Yeah, I took a quick
look at and it seemed like it was nothing burger and boring.
Wow. So, so just to be clear,
some that that that screenshot because I've seen the like the
video of her chat moving, right? It's not just that they clipped
like 10 seconds of it, right? They showed specifically the chat
moving where like almost everyone was like, "Holy Call CPS, whatever."
Right? But that was just like an edited version where it it uh
it only shows the people that typed CPS in there.
I feel like I watched this Denim's video though. Like, how would
I not have noticed this?
Yeah. So, yeah, it was only it was only uh like mentions of like
CPS kids, Jardia or something like that. It was like a couple
of keywords that were filtered down, but the way So, obviously,
initially it's it's brought up on the H3 podcast and basically
they they say about they say about it like um I mean we probably
watch clips here, but they they're like, "Oh, it's edited." And
Ethan's like, "Yeah, yeah, but it's just like it's just like
pulled up and slowed down. It's just like pulled up and it's
just like pulled from the chat and slowed down." And that's what's
been ran with the whole time is, "Yeah, it is. It's obviously
an edited video. You can see it's edited. Look, the chat has
just been pulled pulled out from the top and and they they've
made it bigger and slowed it down." But that's not the only way
it's been edited. The logs are edited. It's filtered.
Yeah. I don't know how they did this. Edited is crazy. Like this
this is edited down to only show Yeah. kids, Gardia,
couple different things. And it still looks like the Twitch chat,
right?
See, cuz I was under the impression that while she was watching
this, like literally like everyone in the chat was like like
call CPS, like he's abusing kids, blah blah blah. So,
where's the data analysis she does where it shows the percentage
of messages that were mentioning CPS within the time frame? 6.8%
in that time frame.
Yeah. So from the first message to the last message that's shown
in that scroll
um it's 956 messages but only 65 of them are shown.
Yeah. So time frame like totally 6.8%. Yeah. I mean and Ethan's
out there. Ethan's out there saying Denims did CPS. Denims did
CPS. People are going oh these guys these people called CPS on
him. They can he can do whatever the he wants. That is the line.
That is the line constantly. And it is like all it's built on
so many
lies first of all like this and second of all people just ditching
their principles just saying it well I mean they would do it
to us so we're going to do it. It's like well no then you just
well that's exactly I for the whole world blind [__]
It's just like okay so we just everyone's now so we just like
we just completely everything. It's everything is censored and
we shut down like all websites
literally any unethical behavior to anyone because Yeah. Yeah.
Oh. Um people do want to point out that Nick covered this. Nick
covered this. I I didn't think Nick covered this. I was pretty
sure that he said this video was a boring. He covered it and
said it was like edited, but I I want to say we should just find
the tweet. He he covered it and said it was edited for
Um, but I want to say it's like I think he basically said it's
like not that big a deal. I am Am I incorrect in in remembering
that guys? I that's my remembrance but I will not stand on that.
I need to see a clip or need to see a tweet. I thought he tweeted
about
Nick Nick is anti denims. He for sure like he definitely has
an issue with like Denim's
He streamed it. I thought he tweeted about it as well because
Denims brought this up and I thought he answered a tweet about
Denims.
Right. Okay. Nick did not cover this video from what I can see.
So Nick did not cover all this. Whoever was saying that it's
just not true.
Well, it wouldn't have covered her arguments directly, but probably
would have covered the snark thread. I'm guessing there was a
snark thread saying
would this have been would this have been the original clip?
And then then I'm Oh, maybe not.
No, it is right. Yeah, it is the original. Okay. So, I think
the argument is basically like, oh, nobody nobody would have
possibly nobody could have possibly thought that this was the
real chat because in the top right you can see the real chat.
So you know that this isn't the real chat because in the top
right you can see the real chat. I want to say that's the argument
that's been made. Okay. Okay. One minute. I I don't cringe on
Maine.
Did Nick cut him addressing this edit into a video? Or is this
purely on stream, his streams that are hidden where oftent times
he'll do things like say explicitly, you know, guys, in this
next segment, I'm not going to take a position on the free speech
aspect of this defamation lawsuit because I kind of hate these
people. And then so so in which situation this occur? Is it something
that happens in in the cutout things or something happens in
the
I'll try to find a find a tweet here that I remember.
Yeah. Look, dude. He's doing this disgusting dude. Look,
bro. Look at this tweet.
Here is Nick tweets. Nick's tweet about denims. Yeah, hold on.
Let's see it. I like the snarker narrative that Ethan claims
Denim's let her live chat scroll up randomly and block the entire
stream.
Anyone with half a brain knows that these chats don't match the
order of the ones shown on screen in the top corner. There is
no context manipulation at all. Yeah, that's what I Yeah. Okay.
So, I did have it right. Okay, perfect.
There's no contextation at all, dude. That's a complete just
lie. Well, no, it's awesome because Auggie just showed up here
and was like, "Wait, I thought everybody was saying this.
See, this is why a debate I do agree a debate needs to happen,
you know?
I feel like we need to see like these ideas clash cuz I only
hear one side or the other. I need to see them clash so that,
you know, all the opinions can be filtered and I can see what
what's really going on here. But um and I'm willing to host it
just to be clear, you know,
whether it's uh with Willie Mack or Diorio
uh
or Queman or JTOK, whoever has like the opposing view and wants
to run it. But I mean, I I do want to see a debate like this
happen
desperately cuz I feel like they're both sides like just have
they have merit and I need to see them clash so I can just, you
know, see what's really going on here. But and I think it would
just be good for the content. I just like the the chat demands
it. The chat wants it.
you know, I'm anti- chat for the most part, but sometimes I want
to give them a little treat, you know, give them something good.
And this debate, I think, would be amazing.
Uh it would be interesting. I like
man I just wish there was like more I wish people just hop on
more informally. I don't know why
it seems like a lot of the people who have come from commentary
YouTube like do not like being seen as like wrong on anything
and I feel like we hop on streams and we make calls like really
fast and I'm just expecting to be wrong on things. So when I
debate people if I'm if I'm wrong that's fine. Well, conversation
is how I figure out for the most part. You know, I can do my
own research. I'm capable of that. But like, usually it's just
through talking to people that I figure out my own opinions on.
And I don't mind looking like a dumbass for temporarily if in
the long term I have more informed opinions. So, dude, I Okay,
pull up this clip, Jay. Pull up this time stamp. Let's watch
the Oreo talk about this. Let's watch talk about this briefly
from the 14th of May.
He sounds way too excited. It gets concerning when he's this
excited. Let's have a look. Let's just This is way too
I want to tell me if he thinks this is a this is a good way of
addressing this point. All right, let's hear it.
Let's BSI, not defamation.
She endorsed this because she's not moderating her chat. Not
defamation. That's literally actually provable true. Just look
at the video. Oh my god. Um and and and no, Ethan, you don't
understand. You manipulated it. You manipulated it by showing
messages on the screen alongside.
It's so stupid, dude. The narrative behind that video is so funny
to me. Yeah, she has the hood now to send me very intelligent
commentary, Nick. I've got to say, you totally debunked that
one, Nick. Well done. Very what a smart guy. This guy's sharp.
Either it's the most man alive or he's dishonest. He's definitely
not. He's I don't think anyone's ever accused Nicholas of being
an actual
Not seriously.
I do think Augg's right when it comes to there's just too much
money in this stuff now. Like he's uh like Nick like last year
I think he got like a thousand concurrent viewers and now he's
like rivaling Destiny with like 8K concurrent viewers. Um and
he he does say like I I have an IRL job. I don't do this for
my main thing. But like that's just it's such an insane amount
of money he's making. He he probably is just terrified. I didn't
actually say I I wanted Auggie to give an opinion. Um I didn't
let him give an opinion before I gave mine, but I I would like
Ter's opinion on that short clip and the context around it. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, he's basically saying that like the video like what
like Ethan editing even if he edits the chat just so I'm understanding
this correctly. Ethan editing the chat to only show the CPS messages
is not bad because it's still showing that these messages existed
in the first place. Even though the implication is is that all
the chat was like this, right?
In the top right corner of the video, there is uh there is actually
the real chat. So when you hit play, the real chat runs, right?
Yeah. This like moving image is just like this spliced together
compilation of everyone saying anything related to kids, right?
And what Dioro is saying is that this doesn't matter
No, let's be clear. No, no. This is quite important. He's not
saying anything. He doesn't finish the thought. He just goes,
"No, Ethan, you don't understand. You manipulator because uh
there's chat on the screen." And then stops talking.
He doesn't take a position. He doesn't explain the argument to
his audience. He is the only goal there is to spoiler any potential
criticism of that video. when the narrative broadly, and he knows
this, the narrative broadly is that Denim's whole chat was spamming
call CPS.
Yeah.
Which is what I literally just thought happened. Yes.
Yeah. It's what everyone thought happened. Anyone that's not
paying like super close attention thinks that happened. Mhm.
Yeah. I mean that I I think uh yeah that's uh definitely something
that should be clarified more cuz I didn't know that you know
and uh that's kind of major. I thought that the whole chat was
just like literally like she was playing bada and like everyone
was like you would think it was like
bombs threatened then cuz if I went live the logic is like if
I went live and for some reason like I'm covering a guy and my
whole chat is like take this man's kids away dox him blah blah
kill this guy like I would notice that it a little bit I would
notice that immediately I'd be like whoa what the is going on
here why is this happening let's let's stop this you know what
I And if Denims witnessed that and was just like, "Ah, just let
it go. Who cares?" I think she would have been liable for criticism
there at the very least. I I'm a very like anti like I I don't
ever enforce streamers like moderating their own chats. But I
do think if like literally everyone is like
at some point you do have to step in and be like, "What the is
going on here?" But that wasn't happening clearly.
And
And there's a there's a a hundred different points like that
where where this is like exactly is just Nick basically playing
soft defense but refusing to take any actual position or explain
anything. It's just like he's just he's just spoilering. He's
just like um trying to put a drag on potential criticism because
he's riding it. He's riding the wave. Well, the criticism is
that he's not spending enough time like providing like necessary
even spend. No, it's not about spending enough time. It's that
when points of criticism come up, he refuses to engage. It's
not you're not spending enough time. It's a deliberate effort
to not present any argument. So, you cannot be criticized firmly.
You can't no one can say totally wrong. You fully believe like
Dioro is like a de dishonest actor at the moment. Yeah. On this
drama, 100% think he's on this drama. I think he knows that he
hates Hassan. He seems to be very caught up about some calling
him a cryptofascist. And he's very cop about the way these lefty
communities have treated him over the years. And he is willing
to use Ethan who is lashing out and doing world stuff and trying
to keep him at arms length so that he doesn't incur too much
damage.
That that is blatant to anyone watching. What is happening? Is
the motiv motivation doesn't really matter cuz he's still doing
it, right? But what is your do you have like any like idea like
why he's motivated? Is it just like a grift or is it for money
blah blah blah? I think everyone's a mixture of like like everyone
when they do anything is is doing it for a mixture of of money
and you know loyalty and you know hating the people they're against
or whatever. So I don't want to like try and guess like the specific
calculation there. Well, I do think Nick seems to have a recurring
pattern of I would say well two points. I don't know if you'd
call that a pan, but it seems like Nick gravitates towards sort
of like a strong figure that he can use to sort of cover and
fight his battles for and sort of he can play soft defense and
try and encourage like um an additional audience to fuel that
because he's done this with Destiny, I feel like, and and I feel
like he's doing this with with Ethan now. Um I think he he he
likes to sort of uh use these use these bigger figures as wrecking
balls.
Um, I mean, I will say in the commentary community, we've definitely,
you know, like our we used to go after Gabby Hannah detractors
a lot, uh, who were like really going out Gabby Hannah super
hard and they were all like these crazy like gay guys in the
T channel community that we enjoyed
up because they were just all insane and stuff like that. So,
yeah, there's probably something like that going on there just
a little bit.
um yeah, I I mean,
you know, you played that clip or whatever. You asked me for
my opinion on it. Obviously, I think if uh if there was more
context to that that explains like Denim's side a bit more, I
think that should be given. And even if you're still anti-Denims
at the end of it, you still think Denims didn't do a good enough
job moderating her chat or counteracting bad's points, then you
should give her side. You should give her side and then explain
why I just showed you critically engage what's being said. Just
actually actually lay out an opinion. Yeah. Yeah.
That's like my biggest problem. That is my biggest problem with
almost any content creator is when they will do this as God is
terminal for this where they will just try and avoid like the
plague giving any actual opinion that you can say okay I disagree
with that because or laying out what what the argument would
potentially be for for the other side you know ever it's like
it's like the most annoying in the world where they just it is
like pure
um
I don't want to say ideology cuz it's not what it is when it
comes to like you a song drama and but you know what I mean?
Like you're just totally captured by an idea.
Yeah. Well, I feel like a lot of creators like it up their flow.
You know what I mean? It's like they're on a roll going at a
specific thing. It's disruptive to the content from their perspective
to just sit there and stop and be like, "Okay, we've beating
up this guy for a million years, but let's stop and sort of,
you know, see how they might be right or at least see like what
their side is and then respond to it again." I feel it's easier
for just pound them over and over again. Trying to like trying
to like like give the other side's argument isn't always like
what you want to do for sure. But but like in a case like this
where there is like ve very important additional context, it
does really change the statements Ethan's making uh and your
Well, for me personally, it makes the content more interesting
to uh explain the bigger story here of like why Yeah. What's
Yeah, exactly. So,
me and Connor try to do that a lot with uh Red Fox Coms and RFC
show where it's like we like to cover drama like the full story
of like what are both where are both sides coming from it and
then we give our opinion and that content I will admit does not
do well at all. People tune out when they hear this cuz when
they hear both sides of the story it almost like overwhelms the
viewer. they get bored or they move on cuz they're just they
can't handle hearing that and they just want to see like you
either suck us on off or on him and so it is counterintuitive
to viewership and money and the viewership uh does suffer from
giving both sides but it is I think I to me personally makes
the content more interesting so
it's just I don't feel like you can honestly like especially
when like people have just become everything they said to Sals.
That's just the reality. Like when you're when you're doing like
this and then Nick is like when there was the embassy worker
and he's like out there day one before the bodies cold, you know,
saying it's an antiic hate crime and then going but I don't talk
about the politics so guys. I don't talk about politics. So guys,
it's like bro, you're just Hassan. You're coming to like some
strong conclusion on very covering breaking news. Isn't that
what people should know on Hassan for? Yeah. on breaking news
and then scolding other people. He was actually quote tweeting
people that were giving like totally reasonable takes and being
like he what did he say? Oh, it must be crazy being in America
because not only does everyone hate you, people bend over backwards
to justify your murder. Mhm. He's like literally out there like
scolding people for being anti-Semitic.
Where are we? What are we doing? Yeah. I
yeah, that's that's that's the part of me that tries to keep
I I you know, I'm obviously not like an apolitical person, but
I try to keep my content apolitical because I'm not trying to
sell an
Anti-semitism required to save lives.
Like basically, you know what exposure therapy is, right? Yeah.
Yeah. Like basically
videos of like being ripped apart. There there are some people
on the internet who are so fragile
towards like ideas of anti-semitism that you might need to be
a little anti-semitic towards them, okay? To like expose them
and just get them like reaclimated so they can live in the world.
All right, Jake. You know, just give him a Yeah, just be like
wake up. You got to wake up anyway. Sorry, Queen. Continue. You
talk about Well, I feel like like Okay, when you have people
that are like so willing to fight dishonestly for a particular
side and they're like this is for the or whatever, right? It's
like you got to be like, "Okay, you're at some point propagating
anti-semitism.
You're literally giving people like you are a trope. You are
a you are a you are
dude." Yeah, this tweet. Scary time for the world right now.
Not only your life, but it will bend over backwards just for
your murder. What does this tweet say? Violence begets violence.
Palestinians have been getting massacred in ongoing genocide
for the last 18 months. Two diplomats for Israel, one German
born and Christian are assassinated clearly for political reasons.
Whether you agree or not, this is not anti-semitism.
Uh, and that's justifying murder to say it's it's not anti-semitism,
but is a political that you can either, you know, agree or disagree
with.
See, I say this is a gay tweet from anyone like anytime somebody's
going on Twitter talking about, oh, it's scary for black people.
It's scary to be a woman, you know. Yeah. This is like this is
like actually you know that you say that there's a little bit
of bo in this.
like nonbinary people heck invalid. Yeah
trans or whatever.
Yeah. Also Twitter is wild. You'll see a complete psychopath
defending a cold blooded antiic hate crime. And now we have a
smiling friends PFP coldblooded anti-semitic hate crime before
before the bodies are before the bodies are cold. Awesome Nick.
And this is the situation where Hassan literally just said like,
"I believe the was honest." And everyone was like, "Oh, yeah."
It was It was uh Yeah. He said he was honest and authentic. Yeah.
Honest, articulate. Yeah. Which I'm sure he was, right? That
doesn't mean you support it, right? Yeah. And someone I believe
he said stuff like misguided and stuff like I believe he did
use that sort of terminology. He said this doesn't help anything.
It was like Yeah. He didn't he didn't go out and say this is
disgusting cuz obviously he's not going to moralize like that
cuz he's trying to be like I understand where people are coming
from when they're super upset with the Israeli government. Like
that's that's his whole thing. So but but he wasn't saying it
was justified or anything like that and people are still like
pro Israel say about like the IDF. It's like this is why they
are so brutal in their tactics because of the
terrorism Palestinians.
Yeah. Yeah. So it's like both sides justify
like violent behavior because it's like well they've been dealing
with this systematically for years. So
yeah, I don't know. This is the same guy who says he never talks
about the
Smaggle, you say you don't care about the conflict, but never
get involved when brown children die only white. What is this?
Oh. Oh, Smaggle making a great
This isn't the conflict. This is a terrorist murdering two in
the capital of the United States.
Should just said politics. Should have just said politics in
the in that tweet and you would have easily robbed him. But Nick
wmed away. Nick totally dishonestly wmed away. I mean, it's bad
dishonestly away from Smaggle.
Say, but the Hold on. The Hold on. The the the guy's entire justification
was the conflict. He kept diplomats from the conflict. It was
obviously relevant to the conflict. Yeah. Yeah.
The accounts that always say the wildest political have cartoon
profile pics
will just generally wandering into room and having no idea what's
going on.
Awesome stuff.
Okay, Sra just said she's going to send me some Aerys clips.
You have an Aerys clip you want to watch? I know I have some
Aerys clips like downloaded or something. Some clips right now,
but but like this is just insane. This is why I'm going so crazy
over this stuff is just saying like this for the last 6 months.
Yeah. So,
you're going after dishonesty, virtue signaling. Uh
yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I just don't want to feel gross like criticizing Hassan. I don't
want to feel like I'm
I don't want to stand shoulder to
get Let's get rid of the rapists. Let's get rid of the pedophiles.
Get them out. Get him out. Let's stop Let's stop crying too much.
Let's stop virt.
Okay. Okay. You got one. You got it in there. It was a little
dog whistle. Who cares? We just be like, you know what? Okay.
Well, my take on the Nazi sword thing was I think that they knew
what they were doing, but not because they were trying to like,
oh, we love swastikas or whatever. I think it was just because
they were trying to like see if Ethan would take the bait. I
would I would believe that if it wasn't a sword that Hassan has
consistently posed with another like the Assassin's Creed Shadow
ship and every time they've pulled out swords
in the room that that's been there and my understanding is from
what said heavy is that the other swords are real swords. This
is the model cosplay sword that is also the longest. So that's
that's the one they pose with. It's like at that point it's like
well that sounds pretty reasonable. I don't know why you would.
It feels like the only reason you would jump to the anti-semitism
[__] at that point is cuz you don't like the guy.
It's like I because that sounds like a totally reasonable explanation.
I've got no reason to disbelieve that. I can see the swords that
are at the back seem like short calling it consistently the swasta
sword in all those clips.
But just cuz you point that out like does that mean that every
time you use it you're doing it for that reason? Like I I if
it's the sword that is the best. Well, if it's like for a photo
to promote your you can climb video, I could see them like just
having like a little feeling like or there just a little thought
in the back of their head like, "Ooh, let's use this one and
see if there's no way he would Yeah. It's obviously unprovable
either way, but I think I mean it's all speculation. Yeah, exactly.
So, you can't really divine it." And I think I think Hassan's
explanation is reasonable. So, I think to go and say, "Oh, this
was intentional. You're you're trying to with Ethan Klein because
trolls because they can always get away from it and be like,
"No, I was just using this." Yeah, exactly. I think you look
stupid if you bite. What's the response to dog whistles? What's
like the intelligent response to dog whistles every single time?
It's just to ask like, "What did you mean when you Yeah, exactly.
That's that's the response, right? Otherwise, you look like a
histrionic."
You mean you just assume that the person making the dog whistle
is doing it intentionally to behave? Yeah. and you just jump
to spazzing out and making a big deal out of it. Literally like
if it is a dog whistle, it worked perfectly.
Yep. Okay. Uh I just got really long a clips. I don't know if
we're going to do these aeros clips. These these might be funny
a clips at another time. Apparently bad empanada is reviewing
some aristocracy stuff and Okay. Don't just blast bad empanada.
That's
I was just like I got to like whoa whoa whoa optics check optics
check optics check do not play bad empanada harassing a woman
so one funny story here with bad empanada in real this is really
funny let's celebrate bad empanada guys yeah for real he did
get one win he did get one win okay he posted in um discord like
oh I'm going to contact the arox mart's brigade or something
that the the the terrorist group from the video game that you
played on stream uh that that I don't believe is a real terrorist
group. Do you guys want to play that game right now? I have it
downloaded.
That's you want to fire that up and go find go find some secretary.
Calm down. Yeah, I'll put that right now. [__] it.
Why not? Yeah. He said he was calling the one Aras and she freaked
the out and started saying he was trying to get and
the [__]
Oh man, I wish I watched the I'd watched the [__]
if it wasn't 18 minutes. I don't know how much longer I'm going
to be here. No, I'm Yeah, honestly I'm like the That's what I
saw. I saw the 18minute thing. I like, "Oh, no. We will find
a shorter clip." Yeah. No way.
dude. I so badly over here wanted to criticize bad empanada for
that Ela Klein thing, but I laughed so hard when Nick Fuentes
went and tracked down Ben Shapiro in GTA that I I'd look like
a if I did it. Okay,
I I myself on that one. She's just always like people in video
games is funny unfortunately and you just have I don't even see
how you could correlate it to like a real life threat. Like I
just don't understand why the crazy they sent him skulls or
that to me that is like much more easier to correlate to like
holy what the is going on here versus like a video game. It's
a video game.
Like if you're going out of your way to do real life CPS
they called CPS and they sent him skulls and his kids under threat.
That was all way that was like years after. No no you don't understand.
No these all of these events occur all at one time. It's like
a it's like a singularity or something. Everything is happening
all at one time. Everything occurred all at the same time and
you can use everything to justify the other stuff. Okay. Maybe
in retrospect,
okay, if all this has happened to you, maybe in retrospect, you
can look back and be like, "Okay, maybe when this guy was playing
the video game, he meant it in a much more sinister way or something
like that." I can see that argument. But it's like when it happens,
like if I'm sitting on YouTube, somebody sends me a clip of some
guy playing a video game where they're like, "I found Auggie
in GTA and I'm right now." It's like I feel like if I reacted
to that, I I would just look like a I don't know.
You think so? Yeah.
Everyone's gone completely crazy though.
I mean, everyone reacts poorly to occasionally, but damn, you
know,
it was just such an L. Like Ethan putting that hilarious clip
of bad and panada like doing the Joker rant to him and like put
like this like scary music over the top of it in his in his video.
It was just like so funny. It's just like why are you why are
you blasting this guy out? Like such traditional
like basic internet knowledge if you've got a really funny hater
with less of an audience than you who is willing to do absolutely
anything. I mean, you know this deal with Sabo, I'm sure. Do
absolutely anything, bro. Absolutely. Caution to the wind. Does
not give a and we'll do anything to with you. The last thing
you do is just stop playing their [__] Turn them
into a badass, you know, turn him into somebody as cool and start
saying that you're like biggest, oh this guy, this guy's evil
and crazy and he's like so insane. Like there's no laws in Argentina.
I can't even do anything to him. It's like you make him sound
like this completely unstoppable like heard this guy.
You just don't Yeah. They literally treat him like he's some
revolutionary militia leader who like who who's having people
like it's so crazy. You just don't respond. Anytime you respond
to a guy like that, you look insane by
you know? You just don't respond. Nobody on the internet understands
the art of just not responding. It's crazy to me. And they think
because just because they're streamers, they're like required
to respond to everything. It's like you don't.
You don't. So you substantive criticism that actually matters.
Sure. You you should I think there is a good reason to Oh yeah.
engage with that. But when it's just like someone who is there
who is just like hellbent on making your life miserable and and
will just absolutely like and they're good at it too, why the
are you responding to them?
It makes no sense. I mean, I feel like they think just the pressure
like people in the chat are going to be like, "Oh, you have to
respond. This guy did something." No,
move on. Ignore. Ignore. Ignore. Block if you need to. Whatever.
The Oh, you don't understand. I have to post 20 Instagram stories
about this. I have to Instagram stories have got to stop, man.
The Instagram I thought tweeting was cringe. Like just like Spurerg
tweeting like when LOL cows just tell everyone everything that's
on your mind. If this says he left Twitter because he doesn't
want to support Elon Musk anymore. No, he left Twitter cuz he
was getting and now he hides on Instagram stories so he doesn't
have to deal with replies and all this. Yeah, cuz there's no
comment section. Yeah. Yep. Exactly. It is the most in the world.
He knows it still gets posted there. He still reads what's happening.
It is such man.
Yeah, it's just so the Instagram stories, man. It's like, do
you think that you're safe there? It's like that I mean, he does
because he's not just getting immediate feedback. Sure, he reads
the internet and he sees everyone quote tweeting them and screenshotting
it and posting their own thoughts, but he can at least justify
in in his own mind because they're coming from communities where
he can be like, "Oh, these are insulated, anti-Ethan Klein communities.
It's not my own fan base telling me this, you know. Cuz
when you see your own comment section turn against you, that's
what makes a streamer or a YouTuber squirm.
Yep. Yep. Yep.
I mean, that's why Ethan freaked out so bad in the first place.
I mean, he audience with with Hassan and they he went in a direction
that they they weren't okay with that he knew they wouldn't be
okay with
um and they turned against him. He got too famous. He got too
big.
That's the problem here. Ethan Klein was never meant to be like
this celebrity micro celebrity figure or whatever the he turned
himself into. He copied Sam Hyde 10 years ago. He copied everything
Sam Hyde ever did. built a YouTube channel with six million subs,
started a podcast back when nobody was doing podcasts.
That blew up, right? And he just got too big and he couldn't
handle it. And ever since he became famous, the universe has
just been trying to correct him. It's been This is very redesque
right now. It's very Mike
I'm just saying it's like he got too famous, he got too big.
The universe has been trying to correct him by sicking the entire
internet on him. And instead of just giving up, he just still
exists and he's just in this perpetual never ending war, this
never ending problem that he's built up for himself and he's
not cool enough to navigate it. Yeah. And the worst part is that
he's risking uh destroying everything for everything everyone
else in the process and completely everything. Yeah. And then
no one's no one's pointing that out. No one saying, "Hey, wait
a minute. You know, maybe we actually don't want fulllength stream
reactions being set into law as as not fair use. Maybe that would
actually set a bad precedent that would make everything a worse
environment." Oh, so I guess we just let all movies be reacted
to on streams forever. So true. So true. Movies
commentary. Thank you.
Brilliant take
you can just maliciously steal views now. So you can just maliciously
steal
I like steal views.
Kenny does do that. You do. You actually do. Kenny, you should
Kenny, you should actually be struck. Ironically,
police videos. He should strike the guy. Three strikes 24 hours.
No translation.
I think everyone who's uh replied to my Twitter in the last 24
hours should be permuted
for being
pissed. Yeah. Ban banned dumb people from the internet. Thanks.
Y via having their head cut off, right? Her from Twitch via having
their head cut off.
Yeah. I mean violently slaughtered in
Okay. Um, listen. I I was like, "Oh, I'm going to wait until
somebody taps out to call it." But I'm at 11 hours in the stream
now, so I'm probably Every time I call into this stream, it ruins
my life, man. Just stand here for two damn long. I'm going to
probably leave for that. I come here every night.
Yeah. Thank you guys for coming on. But yeah, I just think uh
yeah, it was awesome stream. Yeah, thanks for being here. Um
we'll be back tomorrow, guys.
Back tomorrow. Somebody just linked a clip. This is the last
clip we're going to watch. Out like a um multiple calls to action
on my life and Willie M. Like this is the one on Willie. It's
explicit what he wants to happen. Literally anything done to
Willie M show is permissible. Now obviously this is bad empanada
CPS and bad empanada is a who hides behind fake accounts. So
he might say this one is you know here's the thing, you know,
death threats are bad and everything, but I really don't like
this Willie guy. I've got to be honest. So I just don't care
about this. Oh, he's doing it. He's doing it. Oh no.
Oh boy. Well, he is quite annoying and that, you know, that basically
chang
somebody. Yeah, basically I basically just compromise everything
for that. So what what can you say? What can you really say?
It's fake. Maybe it is. Okay, maybe it is. Uh I don't want to
defame anyone here, but ultimately these are this is this type
of that bad empanada does on a daily basis. So if you don't want
uh people to think this is you, maybe you should conduct yourself
better. But bad empanada here or bad empanada account is saying
literally anything on a Willy Mack show is permissible for me.
Uh he's saying that I I live in Miami apparently and he's saying
that people should be interested in receiving payment for an
honest day's work. Uh that we recruit people to print. Now he
wants to print and post flyers. This guy is pretty unhinged.
What the around the city in this one? Um and then now it's I
need to face serious IRL consequences. So this is just calling
for people to murder me. And he's also like this is
dude.
Ah
that is bad. I will actually for Nick I will actually say that
is bad. I I don't agree with that not threatening Nick's life
at all. I totally disavow it. I totally disavow it. But there
are like three people on all of Twitter who had my back in any
way. So I I love the side he's on. I really hate where he's going
with it. Okay. Absolutely no room to Oh my god. You guys are
so bitter. You guys are so bitter against the
told you l What What's he What's he saying? What is the point
here?
What was this clip meant to prove? Didn't he link this?
Uh, hold on. The cringe on main guy. Did he link it? He did.
I got the clip of Banana calling for Nick Dachon to get
Oh, yeah. No, no one ever said that didn't happen. Yeah, no one
ever said that. I think meant to prove is insane or whatever.
Yeah. Yeah. Everyone knows he's insane. Yeah. That's part of
why he's so funny. That's what makes him so funny. It's tragic.
It's tragic that he's so funny. Yeah. It's really unfortunate.
It's like Nick Fuentes, but if Nick Fentes went outside and like
tried to get people hurt. Yeah, for real. It's like tragic. It's
tragic that he's that funny, you know? [__] I mean,
crazy people tend to be funny. So, yeah. It's just like it's
not like I I think he's like a really awesome guy that's doing
good stuff. It's like you're so you're very insane and that's
that does make me laugh, you know? It's like that
kind of like moral right with those texts earlier. this.
Well, no, that that's fine. That's like moral engaged in consensual
race play. Consensual race play with
Oh, you don't know about this?
I know.
Wait, pull up a screenshot quickly. J, just just Yeah,
hold on. To a black woman, by the way, Augie to a black woman.
He didn't just rejoin immediately. He immediately comes back
in here. That's how he's buggy. This is They're being They're
lying. Wait, which race? Which race are you?
It's not good.
Well, I could be any race technically. And nobody knows. It's
It's unconfirmed. I guess your cat is white.
This is This is the screenshot he sent me. I feel like I He's
like Native American or something. Something I am I am significantly
negative Native American. That is true. I knew it. I knew he
was something disgusting like that. So is Elizabeth Warren. Whoa.
I'm part native. What the I'm just kidding. What the
are related by blood? You said you were white in the other chat
either today. I look white. Nobody believes that I'm Native American.
Nobody believes it. Sucks.
I might too. Okay. All right. Big reveal. What was it? We were
just We were like asking this guy like, "Did this happen? Did
this happen?" And he's like, "Well, you want to see like the
most the least bad log from my logs here that's using something
some bad word?" Like, "Yeah, of course." And this was it. This
is one of his lines. What he said.
Absolutely disgusting. A black woman. A black woman that he
That's awesome. I
text this to all of my friends every morning. I wake up, all
of my friends, and I just say this.
into a midnight and it doesn't work. That's the difference.
It doesn't work.
This guy was he got Bro,
the woman actually like imagine you're a black woman. Wait, did
this
were doing race play like it was part of this dynamic that he
would degrade her race. Might not work that well if she leaked
it all. Right.
Really? Well, it worked pretty well.
Wait, you leaked your own set?
Yeah, that's the only thing I've leaked from it. I think she
is the only How do you have to be to leak your own? No, no, no,
no, no, no, hold on, hold on, hold on. I think she talked about
it. She didn't leak like actual, but she talked about it to other
people and then I think he was getting No, no, she she has leaked
actual. I'm surprised they're not going around. So, in response,
you were like, "Here's my version of it." And you leaked that.
What? Well, yeah, it's fine. What? What the [__]
am I supposed to do? Like that to give me five
point trying to prove
he made me money. I said he made me money. Well, you didn't even
leak it on your own stream. You leaked on J stream. You saying
that to prove what? I like this guy. I like this guy. I should
I should get some subs. It was a guy.
I like talking about me. No, it was a You were with a guy. You're
gay. Why? Oh no. I wanted
I literally got this guy to write in Sharpie on his the card
are okay. What the is wrong with you? You're gay. That's gross.
Oh no.
Gay negro worship. What the
what the
man? H listen a I think I think the moral of this story is I
can be trusted. I'm a good I'm a good guy basically. Okay. Didn't
you also leak if you talked to like a 17year-old like a year
someone else? No you did you did leak of that you not she leaked
texts that's for sure of you talking to 17year-old. Well that's
awesome. She shows
to be to be fair she was trying to say that I was like grooming
her or something. So I was like I'm just going to leak everything.
That way I it shows that I'm not there or whatever. You should
huh? Well, you were trying to like sort of hit on her and you
know you were I was definitely flirting with her, but I wasn't
trying to like I I forget exactly what she was saying and it
was it's months ago at point. Well, I completely avowed that
the 17-year-old stuff is based the gay black guy stuff is not
it was a girl. It was a girl. It was a girl. It was not a guy.
I'm not gay. I'm not gay. It was a girl, man. Technically
got it. There's a black woman. Okay. I would never I would never
have sex with a black guy. That's a That's a step too far. Yeah.
A white guy. Okay. Maybe that's We can discuss that. I I guess
not Destiny. Okay. Jesus. Not that one.
All right. You know, that's a what a great end to the stream.
Long enough silence. Yeah, guys, we're gonna head out.
Be back tomorrow. Okay, have a good
Thanks for having me. Thanks for coming on, Augie. Yeah, thanks
for coming on, everybody. Let's go. Good night, guys.